spill 64 and I called representative
Gallagher
okay
so
hello again
um just for the record
uh I'm
representative Eric Gallagher from
conquered Ward 6 which is Merrimack
County District 20. I am here to
introduce house bill
64 and act requiring the commission on
demographic transit to consider data on
race and ethnicity for the purpose of
increasing racial and ethnic diversity
in New Hampshire
so um
yeah
my way of introducing this is going to
be a little bit roundabout but bear with
me so
um yeah I
was born here in Concord grew up in
Concord and one of the things I've
really loved about living in New
Hampshire is our first in the nation
primary
um
our high school
uh
we had a teacher Joanne McGlynn who
would have that ran this presidential
candidates Club where
um
we would organize events where the
different presidential candidates from
both parties would come and speak at
the high school and that was really a
formative experience for me
um politically and part of the reason
why I'm here today
um and so you may remember for example
John McCain
calling me a little jerk during one of
his events like um wrote my college
application essay on that defending his
right to call me one because I was being
a little jerk but um
yeah so and that got me into George
Washington University so but now that
I've returned to New Hampshire
one thing that's changed is that
um our first in the nation primary is
under attack and one of the common
arguments that is used
against us having the first in the
nation primary is that we are not
diverse enough
that we do not have a set of
demographics that are representative of
those of the nation at Large
the thing is when people bring up that
point I don't really have a good
comeback to it like
you know they're right I I agree with
them that
um
that this gate with the first in the
nation primary
should
have demographics that are
representative of those of the of the
nation at large where I diverge from the
other people making this argument though
is that instead of then
giving up and saying okay so therefore
New Hampshire should no longer go first
I instead conclude well then therefore
New Hampshire should become
that state with the representative
demographics of the nation that
deserves to go first
um so yeah I spent some time
thinking about how to do that
um
I first considered a
study committee but then thought instead
of
trying some instead of creating
something new that it would be better to
um
just
do something with a body that already
exists so at first
um
at first I was going to
um so the governor has established his
or well had established I don't know if
it still exists his own personal
diversity equity and inclusion Council
um so I was thinking of possibly
creating a statutory basis for that
um but
um
that
that would have been more difficult than
um
then I had the appetite to pursue at the
time so instead I discovered that we
have a commission on demographic Trends
already which kind of
are already deals with the
um
topic of demographics so I just looked
at the statute establishing it and
decided to add a sentence
to it just adding to their duties of the
advice that they provide
um
so I actually filed this bill last year
too but due to a scheduling mishap I
did not I I did not introduce it um
which led to it being killed and one of
the reasons it died apparently was
because
the commission on demographic Trends had
been eliminated in The
state budget so it was trying to amend a
statute that didn't exist well later
that term we passed another bill to
reestablish the commission on
demographic Trends so now it exists
again so now
the statute
list the statute that we're modifying
should actually exist this time around
so it should actually work
um
so just
to address some points
about it that might come up
um
so it's worded neutrally it doesn't
mention any specific race or ethnicity
if
somehow we were
to if if our racial and ethnic makeups
somehow were inverted it would the
increasing diversity would mean moving
in the other direction
um
so
so the
all of the things that um
the commission does are
advisory
um so
if
if people decide that they don't like
the commission's advice they're free to
ignore it although I don't think that
they should because I um I think they
generally give good advice
um
so yeah it's just
it's a commission that already meets um
they um so and for
for disclosure's sake my father actually
sits on this commission but he doesn't
gain anything
from this legislation though besides
extra work so I don't really think that
makes it a conflict of
um interest or anything
um
so
yeah um
it's a good commission that um and I
think
passing this bill would just help us to
signal to the rest of the country that
we take their critiques of our lack of
diversity seriously and are attempting
to do something about it now you could
argue
the dnc's already
voted to
take away our primary from us but
personally I'm not ready to give up that
quickly I think it's still worthwhile
making the best possible
case that we can
you know because it's going to go
further the secretary of state is
required to schedule our primary first
so he's going to do that and then the
next debate will be whether the DNC
takes our delegates away or not and I
think
um
I think it would be helpful in the
debate over whether our delegates get
taken away or not
to be able to refute
the point about us not liking diversity
here
um
so
yeah um this this bill was something I
came up with on my own it wasn't
something that they asked for
specifically so I don't think
this should be seen as
caving to their demands or anything I
think it should just be
seeing as
um
taking points that have been made
seriously and attempting to do something
about them so
that is my
testimony on this bill and I will take
questions now
you representative Gallery are there
questions representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair thank you
representative Gallagher for taking my
question and just briefly looking at
this and listening to some of your
comments uh you were talking
and I have a keen interest in it too in
the primary and you know I'm very proud
being a New Hampshire person have the
person the nation primary and would like
to keep such but let's focus on the bill
at hand right before us and I'm looking
at it and in the title edge of the
original bill
it's you're basically repeating
what is in the title age so my down home
right to the bullseye type of question
what do you see is the real need of
change here what does that the
commission isn't always doing and going
by your initial remarks which
in your first sentence is what it should
be doing anyways aren't we already doing
it is the question
um so
well all right so there's two parts to
that there uh that I'm going to address
separately one is the title I do agree
that the title is rather long and
basically just
says the same
um text as the bill itself
um yeah OLS
created that title and I would be open
to an amendment to shorten it um as long
as it retains the same basic
um
meaning of it
and as for
um yeah the part about my remarks not
actually being reflected in the bill so
yeah um my initial draft of it um
did include language specifically
mentioning the first in the Nation
primary but that just um
didn't didn't make it into the final
draft OLS didn't think it was necessary
so you can put that back if you think
it's necessary
um
and then so as far as um
what the commission
is already doing so they're actually
when the demographics they're mostly
looking at currently have to do with age
they're mostly looking at um
back in back in 2018 you heard a lot
more about this
um about our silver tsunami of
um our aging population of not having
enough young people to take care of our
older residents so that's primarily what
they're looking at currently
um and yeah I think just having a little
bit of um
extra specificity
could just help nudge things in the
right direction here
thank you madam chair
representative Dolan yes thank you thank
you representative Gallagher uh
we have over 400 Commissions in the
state right now where a good portion of
them never meet
and uh
there is a move a foot to try to trim
that down and eliminate them make
government much more efficient this I
can tell you this is this one is a
candidate to be eliminated uh what are
your thoughts about that
um
I have seen the schedule and seeing how
there is a bill to
um eliminate the commission entirely
scheduled immediately after this one
um
yeah uh I will try to limit my remarks
to the bill at hand now um and I'm going
I am going to be uh sticking around
longer so um yeah I do plan to testify
on the next bill too but um as far as
whether this Commission
as far as this commission it this this
is not one of the commissions that
doesn't ever meet it does actually meet
um
I I think it's monthly if it's not
monthly it's bi-monthly
um but yeah there's there's members of
both parties
um on it I think Senator Hennessey
um was the person running it previously
um so yeah I I think
that
um
thank you madam chair
um thank you for testifying today and
I'm just curious on the
reason for doing this is that the goal
is to increase New Hampshire's ethnic
diversity according to the testimony
we've received today
How would how by collecting data are you
going to increase
New Hampshire's ethnic diversity
and once the state has data like this
what do you think that the state can do
with this Beyond this there's there's
obviously a goal Beyond this based on
what I'm reading here thank you yeah so
well
the thing yeah we do in fact have some
existing pockets of diversity
um
in our state currently like on in
Concord it's more out on the heights
that um where is where a lot of
new um
refugees are settled um and I like in
Nashua for example
um I think they have like one of our few
majority minority house districts
in the state
um
so
I think
um taking a look at
where are
existing pockets of diversity are and
what causes them to be more diverse
could be helpful
and
um
applying those lessons to um other areas
of the state that
um
might want to
so my initial feeling on this is I don't
really trust government and I know that
during World War II the U.S government
used census data to round up the
Japanese so I'm just curious what your
concerns are have you thought about
maybe this data being used for purposes
unintended
um
I mean I think data is data I would
oppose
the use of internment as I I would not
see that as meeting the spirit of this
bill
um yeah um
yeah I think that would
be
illegal if whether the fed the feds
would probably come after us if we tried
doing something like that fans did do it
thank you
yeah well let's we're getting really far
afield from the topic of the bill so I'd
I'd like to concentrate on that are
there any other questions relative to
the bill representative Bailey and then
Gould
wouldn't it be simpler and cheaper if we
just identified as being more diverse
than we are
represented
[Laughter]
perfect question representative cooler
do you think the Census Data is accurate
for diversity in New Hampshire is it
exists
um
I
do not believe
um
yeah I I don't think I'm qualified to
answer that question at the moment
um
but I can
I can look into it and get back to you
about that thank you thank you follow up
thank you representative Gallagher for
taking my question and for being willing
to look into it I think that um that's
something that do you think that's
something the commission could focus on
is how accurately our census data does
or does not reflect the diversity in New
Hampshire
um
I mean
yes that is something that it could
look into
um
yeah I'll just say about that
representative uh Earhart thank you
madam chair
so I'm under the impression that you
believe that diversity in these
neighborhoods is a good thing and it's
good for the state
is that correct yes I do how what metric
are you using to determine that
follow-up please well what so my point
being is in these areas in let's say
Manchester or Nashua or Concord where
it's very diverse what metrics can you
point to that say that this is good for
the State Community Etc
um
mostly subjective ones
um I mean
just as a person I like being around
diversity and I know a lot of my
neighbors do too but I don't have any
hard data specifically and I think
that
um
yeah I I'm not really
sure
what metric would be appropriate
um I I I'm kind of afraid that if
certain metrics
um
if we tried using
um certain metrics here that they could
be misused so
um
I think he's answered your question if
you don't mind
are there any uh relevant questions for
sorry
he said he that the his criteria are
subjective and I think that answers your
question
representative Horrigan
oh
I mean I'm a co-sponsor of the bit of
this bill in fact I was in the Eda when
resident Gallagher's first version of
the bill last year came through and it
kind of uh fell victim to a bunch of
access including the fact that uh
unbeknownst I think even the members of
the committee the committee the
commission had been accidentally deleted
during the Budget Trailer Bill process
while they're renaming uh
what is it called the Department of
Business and economic they were like
renaming what used to be known as dread
they gave it a more name and but anyway
um for and I put in a pink car for the
next bill so I don't want to go on the
top of that bill except to say I think
this is a good commission it's a
valuable one and it's it's I supported
it being revived uh last year in fact it
kept meeting even after they uh they
officially abolished it um
and um
we heard
this is a very simple bill as a Revenant
Gallagher app we pointed out it's cost
nothing and I think it should be doing
it anyway which is considering racial
and ethnic data and I think the goal of
increasing New Hampshire ethnic
diversity is a good one um
first of all I'll say we're the
discovered yet we're the second oldest
state in the Union we have an average
age of 43.1 when the 2020 census was
taken we're just ahead of Vermont which
is 43.0 just
well Maine is even older than us 45.0 so
and main seal just stated so the three
north of New England were the oldest
region of the country so it's not
Florida it's not anywhere else it's you
know it's not
you know it's not the Great Plain State
it's it's us um and I think that's
and we're also one of the less diverse
states in the union we're not quite as
white as some people believe we are we
had got off on
change both reversion Nation primary and
I'm I my personal feeling is in spite of
what was going on uh with the DNC
secretary scandalin will be scheduling
the New Hampshire primary for some time
probably in January um certainly I'll be
voting represent Gallagher I'm should be
voting and
I haven't decided which candidates
support but I'm I would I'm not ever I
might just representative Morgan about
the Bill yes okay so to keep our economy
growing we need to bring in more
ambitious young working people in the
state as our governor said at the budget
address a couple days ago
and that means we're going to bring them
in from other states or even other
countries and younger working adults in
general are more ethnically diverse than
older Generations just because there's a
more people are there's more interracial
relationships people are more tolerant
of them than older Generations might
have been in the places they come from
are going to be much more diverse in New
Hampshire and even uh you know white
well I wasn't actually born in New
Hampshire I was born in Indiana but even
you know white people like me prefer to
stay in a place where anybody of any
color is welcome we don't want to be
around a place
I think it'd be kind of boring to be
around you know have to live in a place
where everybody was looked like me I
like having a variety of people there
and we've been having a lot of trouble
encouraging our young people of any
color to stay
here we're like we're net exporter of
college students for example so more
diversity I think that would make New
Hampshire more attractively for
ambitious young people to uh says my
pursue their dreams or uh of course
there's also the stay work and play
initiatives that's another phrase I
could use to stay work and play in New
Hampshire so please vote not to pass on
HP 64 to keep uh to make New Hampshire
more more vibrant more more diverse
state with a more you know with a
stronger economy and a stronger you know
representative Fitzpatrick
thank you madam chair
so are you saying that the
Commission on demo demographic Trends
doesn't consider race and
ethnicity now well that's uh is that
what this is that what you're saying I'm
just I'm just affirming that they that
they should be I I'm not familiar with
it as representing Gallagher is my look
at the minutes of some of the meetings
yet they I mean they have been
considering it and certainly uh there's
data not just in the decennial census
but in the surveys the Census Bureau
takes every year there's other data and
they it's just they already are
considering it but this just like
encourages them to consider it even more
at least that's my understanding
follow-up see what I'm trying to figure
out is what's broken that you're trying
to fix
um well we are happy
we are having trouble uh our con one
thing's just stifling our economies is a
shortage of uh you know young young
people who are raising families who are
at the prime of their career and um one
of the things
I mean there's many things that are uh
discouraging people from moving here
from elsewhere and discouraging young
people staying at saying part of it
maybe is the perception that we're very
white and white bread type of state and
I think also the younger generation is
it wants to be around diverse people you
know they don't even though
even though like white supremacist
groups get a disproportionate amount of
attention most people are in New
Hampshire and across the USA are very
tolerant and want to live in a tolerant
place and also say like your community
in Rochester for example and Resident
O'Brien's those are
to places that are doing a lot to drive
the growth of our of our state not just
within their own City Limits but you
know Statewide and those are also two
relatively diverse diverse places and
getting more diverse so
thank you madam chair I I didn't get my
question answered oh sorry well I'm sure
very good are there any other questions
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair I know time is nice so I'll be
struck to the point representative
Oregon 45 seconds uh taking my question
I see you kicking the ball for a very
good goal yeah okay but I don't see the
follow through and the thing is I agree
with representative
in like her question collecting data and
everything else but in the example and I
I would like to thank representative
Gallagher for recognizing what the good
people and the citizens of Nashua have
done Workforce housing other different
things I mean maybe this commission is
okay maybe we should channel into
something else I mean is a problem with
the bill is it the data collection or is
there other issues well it's just a very
simple bill which costs nothing and so I
certainly agree
you know all the data is useless unless
we're following through on it but that's
a matter for other bills in other
communities this is just a small step
does anyone else wish to testify on
seeing none
and open the public hearing on House
Madam chair members of the committee
my name is Gerald Griffin
and I represent Hillsborough 42.
consisting in the towns of Mount Vernon
linebro and New Boston
I'm the sponsor of HB 228
HB 228 repeals a section of RSA 12
and by doing so eliminates the
commission on demographics
the current Commission on demographics
was created last year
by HB 1106.
that same bill
eliminated the previous Commission on
demographics
to put
hb228 in perspective
it is helpful to look at the history of
the earlier Commission
and with the chair's permission I will
do that
I believe the initial commission was
created in
2016 and arose from an earliest study
group
recommended that the State hire a
demographer
um
then then representative Hennessy latest
he was a sponsor of the initial bill
she later became the chair of the
committee
that initial bill called for the
commission to support a newly created
demographer position
and consider any legislation that might
arise as a result of that support
the demographer position was created but
to my knowledge it has never been filled
and so from its outset one might say
the initial commission was a commission
without a mission
now back to HB 228
there are four reasons I put the bill
forward and I'd like to outline those
for you
first it is a commission with a vague
mission
the underlying law says in part
the commission will create a biennial
scorecard on New Hampshire's demographic
suggests to me
that we measure against some objective
standard
but the law is silent on what that
standard is
secondly
the commission is a duplication of
ethics
professor
Andrew Johnson and his team over at unh
study demographics and death
and produce excellent reports
at one of our recent Finance hearings
I asked Peter Caswell the director of
the Department of Business and economic
Affairs if his Department used those
reports
he indicated they didn't they did in
fact use those reports and use UNH as a
resource on demographics
those of us who serve in finance and
ways and means
spend several days at the beginning of
each biennium getting up to date on the
New Hampshire economy the housing market
the real estate market and of course the
changing demographics of our state
this last month Professor Johnson
delivered his report
and it was very detailed and very well
done
third the underlying laws deficient in
several respects
the law is vague about its mission
the law calls for membership as follows
for house members one Senator the
director of the Department of Business
and economic Affairs or his steps in
need and six members from the public
that's 12 total members
with seven members constituting a quorum
during the time I served on the earlier
Commission
the most public members we ever had was
two
both of whom were excellent and brought
much to the table
but we started with a deficit of four
public members which did not leave much
room for error
in fact as the first named House member
of the new Commission I call the
organizational meeting of that of that
Commission
to elect a chair
only three members showed up
and without a quorum I recess the
meaning until such date as a quorum
could be found
that date has not yet arrived
finally for All Above reasons
this commission is a squandering of
valuable resources that should not be
spent
in the duplication of work that is being
done so well by our own unh
we only have 24 senators and we know
each one of them as stretched very very
thin
I know the speaker's office is often
challenged to fill the many positions
resulting from the many some say too
many some say way too many commissions
and study groups we have created
finally we are fortunate to have
citizens who are willing to help and
contribute their time
but we must ensure that we ask them to
serve in a meaningful way
and that we don't squander their
participation
I know they are a squares resource
because during my service on both the
prior commission and the current one we
never had more than two public members
despite in the case of Alaska Mission my
repeated requests and emails to fill the
vacancies
we heard previous testimony just before
yours that uh the work on these
commissions
is free that doesn't cost anything uh
especially in light of mileage to be
paid
people from state government to fulfill
uh clerks to publish
the uh the minutes and the the notes do
you agree that that these don't cost
anything
No in fact that's why I'm here these
commissions are very expensive and in
terms of uh the number of house members
a senator and the general public so we
should be very very careful how we spend
those those people who basically
volunteer
that time we should be very careful how
other questions
you're representative brother
so I just want to make make sure I
understood what you said so that the the
commission on demographics hasn't really
been as a result of the legislation that
was passed recently has not met is that
correct
I'm sorry I didn't let me speak a little
bit louder
I just want to make sure that I
understood what you said in your
testimony that the Democrat the um
Commission on demographics that was
originally that was set up in the most
recent legislation has not met is that
correct
it I did call the organizational meeting
of the most recent legislation
and uh as I said three people showed up
three people is not a quorum
so I recessed the meeting until such
time as there was a quorum I checked a
few days ago to see where
the membership of that committee stood
and currently there is only one name
on that committee and that name is as a
House member
and unfortunately that particular House
member lost their election in the last
election cycle so literally there's
there's no one currently assigned to the
commission
Clee you were unable to your Quorum
because
appointments to the commission were not
there were appointments made to the
commission the speaker's office did make
appointments
um I can't speak for the the Senate has
to make their appointment
and the public members typically are
appointed I Believe by the government I
know by the governor's office I know
there were
the house members were appointed because
I was one of them
uh I can't speak for the other entities
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and this is
probably a little bit of a question
towards you I know there's a special
committee on committees and commissions
areas like this going to be addressed in
that committee or special committee and
I'm just wondering whether we should
wait to act on this because if this is a
recommendation you know we should
probably take action at a later date
with the chair of that committee is
representative Dolan so I'll ask
[Laughter]
him short answer is yes
excuse me are you saying we should not
pass this bill to save you the work
filling this commission this will this
issues like this will be addressed in in
that that committee committees that
don't meet or that don't have time to
meet or are
gone by the issue has gone by and this
particular bill this particular bill is
is not on our docket yet but uh it will
be one of the first ones that
the first commissions that we'll be
looking at to try to eliminate it uh and
save save some government you know
government spending
would you feel we stepped on your your
committee's toes if we uh
um actually I think this is more for the
executive session than for the fence of
the hearing I apologize are there any
specific questions to representative
Griffin
yes represent gold and representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question and you may not be
able to answer this but I wondered if in
the um reports you look at from
Professor Johnson at UNH if UNH is
reporting race data as part of the
demographics that that you've seen
uh absolutely the work they do over
there is very complete they they not
only have the U.S census I believe they
use the University's ability to do
polling within the state of New
Hampshire
and so uh it's a resource it's it's
available to the legislature it's a
resource that uh director Caswell told
me he uses
and uh his area of Business Development
includes the planning
Department
which the demographer was supposed to be
part of
so yes uh very very good work done over
question is actually for the chair also
or perhaps representative Dolan is there
a means by which committees that are
confronted with items like this can
officially refer their bills to that
committee if
some bills have been referred to those
committees
this is not one of them so therefore
it's on our plate to make a decision
if we decide not to pass this bill then
the that commission is committee is
still
able to review it under their chart
okay my my question though is it seems
there should be a mechanism one would
think so but but this is not an early
Bill therefore it is not one of the ones
that would be referred to that
commission all right they've got to
research it on their own thank you
Brooks on Dolan I it is this if it's
process let's finish with the the
witnesses first
we can okay any other questions of
represent a bear please excuse me
thank you madam chair
um thank you for your testimony today
and I was doing a quick search trying to
find the
annual report that's supposed to be
filed with the governor the Speaker of
the House
if you could send me that link that
would be handy thank you
you're not alone in having that problem
when I first got appointed to the prior
committee I pulled the file from the
fourth floor of the office building just
told me and I went through that file and
I was unable to locate a single report
that had been done and as far as the
most recent committee the one where he
had
talking about
uh we had we have uh never met with the
s on Fitzpatrick
thank you madam chair
if
your commission had been meeting and and
doing what it was uh tasked to do would
you be
considering data on race and ethnic
background
I I it's hard for me to answer for a
whole commission but as as as a member
that's the the charge of the commission
really was to look at demographics and
it was one of the underlying on one of
the underlying problems with that was
we first had to educate everybody on
that Commission
on demographics and so typically what
would happen is the commission would be
appointed a chair would be appointed
and then we would have people come in
just as Ways and Means and finance does
at the beginning of each biennium
and they would testify and present
situations on the demographics and
housing and the economy and all the
related items and yes that's uh that's
what demographics is
thank you representative Griffin
I um representative Gallagher again
um
so
yeah I'll keep this short since
um but yeah basically since my previous
Bill assigns additional duties to the
commission I would oppose the disbanding
of it as that would conflict with my
previous bill I think as to the point of
one of the reasons to disband it being
its mission is vague well I think that's
one of the things that my bill helps
with is that it makes it less vague as
to the point of the um
data also being available
from UNH well
your unh
works together with
people on this committee so
um
I think there is a possibility that
removing the committee could
arm the quality of unh's own data
um
and
yeah I think
um
I think having it be
um and
official
State body rather than a university
one uh
helps to give it extra credibility and
um
just
it it provides it provides a different
purpose than the university might and um
so I think it's worth keeping around and
I'll take any questions
um
I don't see any questions so
thank you thank you very much I
represent Timothy Horrigan from
Stratford County District 10 which is in
fact the home of unh and certainly UNOH
does have
um
a white history of a strength in the
area of demographic and social research
and um but and the commission if we and
if we can if the commission I think
complements complements compliments that
work um
I'm not sure if they cost these
commissions whether you're consider the
mileage very expensive or not that's uh
you know it's usually
that only kicks in if the person makes a
special trip to Concord or whatever the
commission is meeting anyway if you're
already going to conquer you don't get
double mileage for attending the
commission at least I hope that's not
how it works I have to confess even
though I've been here 13 years I've
never served on a statute a statutory
I've never been one of the people any of
the speakers as appointed to a statutory
Committee in fact I don't even recall
really
being actively actively invited the of
all the speakers I served on the one who
was the most interested in filling these
seats was uh my first speaker speaker
narelli and it's been less of a priority
for the other speakers and uh
man you think I probably did get it we
did get some somewhat perfunctory email
from our Majority Leader saying if
you're interested uh join but hasn't
they're not really very actively
recruiting the house members for these
committees in my appointment I am have
been a member of two of a committee and
also then a board
um that's under the Aegis of the
Secretary of State's office which isn't
technically a statutory committee
because they did it on their own
authority and um yes representative and
uh this Bill yes so I think if the uh
I think the mission I think obviously
there's an endemic problem and actually
well actually where that connection is
the Secretary of State's office is very
strong institutional support for the
boards and committees that are under its
purview so you know they in fact uh
Senator Hennessey who wrote the Bill
that reconstituted the committee was one
of the people invited me to be on the
boards and I'm on now but um and she
strongly supported keeping the
commission around but um
so I think maybe we may be more
institutional support for all these
committees statutory committees but I
think this one is particularly valuable
one because uh we need
you know we need to become a younger and
more diverse State you know we need
ambitious young people coming
um from other parts of the country
they're more diverse than ours we need
to keep our ambitious young people who
grew up here in New Hampshire growing
New Hampshire and um so the issues
and certainly the issues that the
previous Bill addressed are amongst
those at the state government has to
address in order to keep our young
people here and also um
and that's this commission is a valuable
resource from it regardless of whether
or not it's actually being
reaching its full potential which it
apparently at the moment it's not
um so and you may need to you may need
to uh you may need to restructure it uh
Red's just having the six members
appointed by the governor hopefully
since he actually talked about this in
his budget address maybe filling those
six slots has now again become a higher
priority for his office but yeah so I
think anyway we should keep the
committee around and that
that doesn't uh necessarily it doesn't
necessarily change the fact that there's
the committee on commissions and other
bodies are looking at all these
committees commissions and so forth but
this particular one uh we should keep it
around we should keep it around and we
should make an effort to uh make it more
viable so thank you
thank you representative Oregon yeah
thank you madam chair for the record
Peter Schmidt representing Stratford 14
which is a
city of Dover award Ward one
um and I decided to speak on this issue
because uh I had the privilege about
15 years ago I think to hear a lecture
over at the tuck Library across the
street
by Peter Francis
who is a very noted demographer I'm not
sure whether he has died in the meantime
I hope not because he's a brilliant guy
and very knowledgeable it was a an
extremely instructive
presentation that he made and I've just
sent you a uh an email forwarded you an
article by Brad cook who's a noted New
Hampshire attorney uh on this and he's
writing on the subject of demographics
in New Hampshire among other things
and I I would ask the chair to
distribute it to the rest of the
committee because
I think we abandoned this committee or
Commission and that representative
Griffin has talked to us about at our
own Peril while I sympathize with him in
his uh
dearth of
committee members or commission members
I know what it's like because
I'm uh I was the surviving member if you
will of the
joint committee on employee
classification
and it's one of our very important
committees
please bear with me I'm only taking a
few minutes
um
and the the thing is the governor and
his staff are extremely busy in terms of
filling uh required committees and
commission positions uh and it may be a
while before he uh he can he and his
people can get around to this current
commission so I sympathize with
representative Griffin
um but demographics is is like gravity
you can't get away from it and uh and
the reality is that if we don't know
anything about New Hampshire's
demographics
aside from the fact that that Professor
Johnson is doing an admirable job but
the state also needs to be on top of the
situation so I think we need to think
about it very carefully before we
um jettison this particular commission
and I urge you all to read the email
that I just sent to to uh representative
McGuire because uh it's the our
demographics are a slow dive off the
diving board the dive can be slow but
once you're off the board gravity takes
over so and demographics are already
doing a number on the state of New
Hampshire so thank you I'll I'll answer
any questions anybody may have
representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair
I'm just a little confused as to why the
government has to be doing this
for instance U-Haul tracks where
why do you think the government should
be doing this you mentioned that
specifically in representative Gerhart
is questioning why you think that's
important
well I we have a lot of functions as the
members of the state legislature and uh
so that that's one of our functions is
to determine whether certain things are
wise in in our judgment as a committee
um and uh I'm not sure that the
government necessarily has to be the
only one doing it but to the degree that
you have something as absolutely crucial
to the further uh benefit and survival
of the State of New Hampshire As We Know
It uh I think the government
ought to be paying some attention to
that
okay follow up
well the reason I'm saying this is first
off U-Haul and other companies actually
track where people are moving from
within the United States
so they can say for instance this is
2021 but Tennessee was the state that
most Americans were moving to for
instance so Mike my concern is just the
government is not most likely to be the
most accurate producer of this
information
when it's can be tilted by the political
winds as we've seen recently last couple
years so I'm just concerned about
putting all that you know what I'm
saying it seems like a waste of money
that's what I'm concerned about but
thank you
I take your point but uh I think that
that's our function as the Edna
committee is to examine the bills that
come before us and the issues they raise
and to exercise our best judgment on
Mr Clegg do you wish to testify on this
bill
okay well Casey's the only other person
here so I will close the public hearing
.
we're going into executive session
does someone have emotion about House
Bill 64 which is the first one we heard
this morning
Madam Cheryl yes itl all right is there
a second
okay shoot and
gold
how would you like to speak to your
motion
yes um actually I'll uh
I'll read the committee statement that
I appreciate it
um uh one of the goals of this sponsor
are laudable uh there does not seem to
be an appetite on the part of the
legislature or the executive to fulfill
this since they did not provide the
necessary appointments the testimony
indicated that UNH wishes to study this
issue and there's nothing preventing
them from doing so and they certainly
would share any findings and information
with the government if we ask
okay representative Gould do you wish to
speak to your second I think um
representative schuett said it well I
would
um just add that
in an environment and and I've heard
this for the last 10 years the
aggravation with the number of
commissions and the expense and to keep
a commission that is clearly not being
active and doesn't have any
representative
I just wanted to make sure you know
what's about how 64. right and sending
the scope and so
um
expanding the scope of a of a commission
to replicate something that UNH is
already providing uh
doesn't seem necessary thank you
representative O'Brien thank you for a
different reason I am uh I am not going
to support this I yes dispel the
original commission is very lofty I
think it's worthwhile it should be in my
opinion should be kept to take a look at
but what is being done out of this and
to me it's like in the good golf swing
it's the follow-through so what is the
follow through with this it's time to
look and it is not covered in this bill
or not should be covered in this bill it
should be other things to start looking
at Workforce housing other type of
things that would increase the
demographics in a particular community
so if the fixing of the demographics is
what we need to fix I think this bill
falls short and actually compiles the
information
but it could fall short of the fall
through to reach that lofty goal thank
yeah my representative Gerhart thank you
madam chair
my concern is
worse
I'm gonna hold off comments okay thank
you I I'm representative Dolan I just
wanted to get a clarification uh
representative O'Brien just said doesn't
support you don't support the itl or
don't support the the commission
he doesn't he supports the itl because
the bill does not support its goals got
it is that correct right yeah exactly it
it identifies another problem one that I
think is a bigger there's something else
thank you madam chair I will not be
supporting this bill based on one fact
the bill says that basically we want to
measure what we have for diversity in
New Hampshire yet the testimony
contradicts that by saying we want to
increase the diversity thank you okay
all right yeah I'm
I don't know much about demographics but
I do know that race at race and
ethnicity are
what one of the components of
demographics and if we have a commission
on demographics it will automatically
consider race and ethnicity so I don't
think it's necessary to tell them to do
that
uh
and so I'm supporting the itl
anybody else
okay in that case the motion is itl on
House Bill 64 and the clerk can follow
the rule
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan
representative a bear yes representative
Gerhard yes clerk vote Jess
representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes and we got about 16 years
the motion passes 16 to zero uh is there
any objection to consent
okay see none we'll put that one on
consent
and
do you think we should consider House
Bill 228 as well or should you do okay
representative bro did you have a motion
I do I um move auto pass on to on
Hospital 228
president Gerhard all right opening
crowded you so speak to your motion I do
I've served on several several
commissions
and
these commissions are important to my
constituents
and I can tell you that as the chair of
these commissions
I spend a significant amount of time
um people's appointments
and it's not because people don't care
it's because they are busy
we have
a lot of responsibility as legislators
in New Hampshire
so that when an organization like the
college the University of New Hampshire
is doing something
and the work is being done by people
that are experienced and knowledgeable
I think it's important to partner with
our institutions such as UNH to to help
so I'm disappointed to have heard that
the commission did not meet
there were no reports
and
although when we're talking about money
we're not talking about mileage
we're talking about people's time I
don't know about your time but my time
is valuable I place a value on the
amount of time I spend coming to Concord
sitting on commissions going to
delegation meetings and I do those
things because they are valuable to my
constituents and therefore valuable to
me but my time is worth something
and I'd like to think that everybody has
that viewpoint
so I'm sorry if I sound I just when
people say to me things don't cost
anything it drives me crazy because it
does
so um
so I don't if the commission's not
meeting
I just don't think we should continue it
I would recommend that we take a look at
it again at a dude you know I mean it's
such as a tiny little scope and I think
that if we're going to do something like
that we should look at it as a whole
thing
and you know you can you can increase
affordable housing but then when you're
going to force people of certain
demographics to go there I mean that
so um
I think this is serious so I think that
you know these are all the reasons why I
support passing this and this is not
easy
because I do believe in diversity I do
believe in having but if it's not going
to happen it's not going to happen you
can't force something like that I don't
believe you can
anyway I'm so sorry this is so
long-winded but I think it's important
to talk about these things and to
express our thoughts on this because
thank you representative Gerhard is to
speak
thank you madam chair
I will agree with with representative
Gorda that time is valuable and I don't
think it should just be calculated in
knowledge and sense
and I I really did not realize the
amount of time involved with this whole
conquer gig until I actually got here
and this is you guys yeah anyway so
I just as far as the demographic Trends
and stuff and I understand that we want
to increase young families move to New
Hampshire but I'm I think that's more
accomplished through the free market and
just lowering taxes and making it easier
for families to live here I don't think
it's a matter of putting up the right
billboard on the Massachusetts border or
any of that kind of stuff I just think
just you need to make the society that
you want so if you want more people to
have kids offer to take care of people's
kids and stuff like that I just think
it's a local individual level so point
being I agree and thank you
okay thank you other comments
representative Schmidt of course
is opposed
so I oppose uh an ought to pass because
most of us even myself do not know
enough about this subject and we're
throwing away a commission
we should be retaining this bill to find
out it sounds to me like the structure
of the commission is flawed at the very
least uh I I don't see any reason why
there should be four Reps for example on
such a such a commission we know that
the Senate you know doesn't like to
serve on these committees and and the
bills in my early years here the
commission the such bills always had two
or three senators and every time
virtually the the the Senate would strip
it down to one Senator so uh they they
are really stretched thin as I'm sure
even the freshmen recognize it's a 24 7
job if they're going to do it right uh
and and some of the people do not have
that kind of time so but uh but the
point is that to abandon this commission
when some of us know next to nothing
about the demographic situation and we
need to get informed before we junk a
commission that's looking at
demographics so I will be opposing the
ought to pass thank you okay
I also representative gold
now is one I can say my my part about
with we have commissions that are really
urgent and with such a trend toward
overtaxed and overuse that we heard from
representative Griffin
um and everyone else's testimony I think
it's important that we focus the limited
resources on matters that are Urgent
which isn't to say demographics isn't
urgent but I really like the fact that I
heard from representative Griffin that
UNH is providing the information so we
all can get educated about demographics
thank you
representative uh building and then
Lexus
thank you madam chair and I want to
thank representative Griffin for trying
to get this ball started and you know
unfortunate that
we didn't have the folks there available
and also thank him for the information
brought forward that the university
system is providing some of this a great
deal of this information and it is being
used by both finance and Ways and Means
which is good to hear that that
information is out there and available
and I think we all know that with this
special committee we are looking at a
number of committees and commissions
that we are over taxed with here and
trying to support with the limited
amount of time legislators and Senators
have that if information is available
without having to put together a
commission or committee that is the way
to go thank you
thank you and uh yeah I understand the
the desire to educate members of the
House on this but I I don't see that
having this commission would be
particularly effective what might be
more effective is you know get a notice
in the calendar to let everyone know
that this resource at UNH is available
link off to the report and if they want
to get into it further let them know how
they can contact the people there I
think that'd be much more effective than
creating this commission which may even
if it does meet it might generate a
report I think it I don't know that it's
going to be it's unlikely to be anything
better than what we already have in UNH
thank you thank you
it's not right in that case the motion
is ought to pass by representing Broda
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Garrett yes clerk
vote Yes representative
yes representative Schmidt no
representative goalie yes
representative shruitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative David Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
14 years two nay
oh in the chair I'm sorry I voted for
um 15 to 10. uh no because there's 16
people here
okay 14 the motion passes fourteen to
two uh do you object to consent
okay it'll be on the regular calendar
does it do uh either of you wish to put
write a Minority Report
I'm debating
uh if so at your very earliest
convenience
and let me know as soon as you decide to
do so must representative Davis wants to
no okay
hey trust me a majority report is easier
all right uh in that case we are I'm
um
foreign
all right I would like to open the
public hearing on HB 564 and welcome
representative
McGuire
yes thank you I'm Carol McGuire
representing uh the towns of Allenstown
Dunbarton Epsom and Hooksett
and
relevant to this bill I was I'm the
chair of the committee to recommend
amendments to the building code
and this
and this bill was a recommendation of
the committee to do to recommend
amendments and it recommends amendments
um
the building code review board met in
November
and approved number of amendments which
I sent out to you last night
and this bill
ratifies those amendments to the State
and the fire fire
uh
the State Board of Fire Control
recommended some in September and it
this ratifies those as well
um
the leaders of both the building code
review board and the board of Fire
Control are here if you have questions
about the details of the amendments
I'm just here to say that there
they were recommended by the relevant
boards and as far as I can tell we
thank you very much are there any
questions
yes representative Groton thank you um
and perhaps
you might be able to end this this but
maybe one of the boards might were the
changes
um
I'm just trying to I'm looking for the
word will the change is motivated by
safety or changes in available
technology do you know
uh you you'd have to get the details the
ones that I remember specifically were
to settle conflicts within the codes or
to allow options that were needed okay
that answers I'll give you the details
okay thank you
yes representative O'Brien uh thank you
uh Mr chair
um
representative McGuire looking at the
face of 564 and by committee I don't
mean to hang it up on that it says
education should that really
in future be read as uh you know Edna uh
I don't know why this went to education
but as you could tell it was very
quickly vacated to them so it was
yes representative blackis thank you uh
of course is either to you or if there's
someone else who can answer it better
um I haven't had a chance to review the
changes thank you for sending them but
the question is
um what changes if any uh that are being
proposed
um are expected to increase the cost of
building in any way that gets into the
concern well anyway I believe you should
well you should ask the other people for
the details I don't have it I don't
understand right thank you done well
enough to answer that question
anyone else
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee I think I can answer some of
the questions that were asked I'll
provide a quick summary statement and
then I have copies of each of the
Amendments if anybody wants to get into
the details so the building code review
board is pleased to forward eight
building code amendments to the current
New Hampshire State Building Code with
our recommendation that these be
ratified these Amendments have been
reviewed and approved by the board after
a public hearing and they include three
amendments which relax energy
requirements for changes of occupancy in
existing buildings so that's a reduction
in cost four amendments that came out of
the Greece Interceptor study with Des
last summer and that was there's
probably no difference in costs that
just sorted out who is enforcing what
and how some things were defined to
bring our code into into alignment and
Des into alignment so we met in the
middle on some of that uh
and one Amendment came from the solar
industry uh in the in the main building
code
we referenced the fire code for solar
panels on roofs we neglected when we did
that in 2018
to fix the international residential
code which applies to single-family
homes so all that Amendment does is pull
out the explicit requirements in the IRC
and reference the state fire code where
all of that solar stuff was worked out
so that was more a housekeeping issue
but in fact it will it will save some
money over the model code
uh
a ninth amendment just just to keep you
in the loop involved some flood zone
requirements was not approved by the
board and it's under further review so
that may come back later so thank you
for your consideration happy to answer
any questions
thank you very much any questions yes
representative like us thank you um yeah
thank you for those answers and and I'll
be uh looking at the Greece Interceptor
stuff again
um but my larger question on cost is
well first of all what building code are
we operating under now and if we're as I
understand it this is looking to adopt a
newer building code
what changes between those two would
you know would increase cost and any
general ideas to what extent so these
are amendments to the current building
code we're not going to a new model code
we're on the 2018 cycle with the 22
National Electric 2020 National Electric
Code none of these apply to that code so
these uh all amend the code that's in
place now we're in a little bit of an
interim year next year uh if things
progress as we expect we'll be back here
to change the model codes to the 2021
series of the seven seven that make up
the building code the electric code Will
Follow by a year
okay thank you
representative
can you be more specific about the
in the model code if you are altering a
building so I I have an office building
and I'm going to do some Renovations
it's still going to be an office
building there's a shopping list of
things that you do not need to comply
with energy conservation for instance
instead of having to provide the proper
amount of insulation in a wall it only
kicks in if you if you open up that wall
and then you only have to put as much
insulation as will fit you don't have to
build a new outside wall
if you change the occupancy in the model
code none of those exceptions applied so
basically if you went from an office to
a retail store you'd have to meet the
energy code as though it was a new
building so what those amendments do and
there's three of them that just pick up
the different parts of the code
basically say that that list of
exceptions that applies for alterations
can also be used for changes of
occupancy therefore reducing the cost to
its effective reuse of a building if
somebody wants to change what they're
doing with it it results in less energy
conservation just for practicality
follow up follow up
so this is for commercial space though
or is it just change of use for
commercial to residential or is it only
within the commercial commercial sphere
one and two family dwellings
but it does kick in for other
residential multi-family dwellings
okay thank you you never change an
occupancy for a one and two family
dwelling or it's not a one and two
family dwelling anymore
thank you Mr chairman
welcome Mr chairman uh I my question
goes to one of your remarks about uh a
blending of uh two sets of codes I think
the building code the plumbing code or
whatever and and I'm wondering uh
whether you are referencing or we're
referencing this working group that you
and I
representative McGuire and several a
number of other very experienced
staffers and Craftsmen and so forth from
both the plumbing side and the
the Environmental Protection side and so
forth uh work together is that the the
working group that you were referencing
in in your remark about one of the
changes that this bill would Institute
that's correct uh you'll recall that
coming out of that we issued a report
and said that Des was going to amend
their rules through their process we
were going to amend the the code
Provisions through the amendment process
so a couple of those amendments apply to
the international plumbing code and a
couple apply to the residential code
because we had to hit different sections
of those codes
thank you very much
representative LeBron
um I did have a question but uh not so
much as for the gentleman but uh to uh
assist representative grotta but I think
it could be best uh handle and I was
going to mention what the term we use in
the business grandfathering but I think
that could be handled in executive
session so thank you thank you
say no further questions thank you for
foreign
my name is Sean Toomey I'm a State Fire
Marshal I'm going to speak specifically
to the fire code provisions and changes
we're currently in the 2018 State Fire
code as as adopted and ratified by the
general court we've looked at two
amendments to the fire code in the last
few months that came up that we need to
address and the first one is relative to
NFPA 37 which concerns generator fuel
lines there's a requirement in the code
that you were not allowed to have a
valve with a handle on it and the fuel
line from the fuel tank to the generator
for some reason what we discovered
working with Des is they needed to they
also need to tightness test the fuel
line to make sure there's no leak and
without that valve you can't do that
properly without taking the whole
assembly apart and then trying to put it
back together which kind of defeats the
whole tightness testing so the there's
very similar language in from a fuel
tank to an oil burning appliance that
allows the valve in place and you just
remove the handle so typically people
wouldn't mess with the handle after the
tightness testing was done so we align
the language in NFPA 37 to have a valve
in place and the handle removed so it
matches the two appliances and it allows
proper tightness testing from
environmental perspective from a cost
perspective I'm guessing the valves will
touch more but there's probably less
label labor taking it all apart and
trying to defeat that part the Second
Amendment I'm just going to speak to
briefly but it's going to come in as
part of the amendment I think
representative Maguire will speak to a
minute but if you want I can speak to it
later or now it's I guess it's up to if
it's about the amendment specifically it
will hold off until we get to the
amendment 108 okay so if as the bill is
right now that though that's the only
one that's being contemplated until the
amendment comes in I have one other one
to add then so any questions happy to
answer them
sing none thank you very much thank you
would anybody else like to testify on HP
so you know what I'm going to close the
hearing and I am going to open the
hearing on Amendment 2023-0091
or HB 5664 and welcome back
representative McGuire
yes thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Carol McGuire mayor Mack
District 27 and this is this amendment
is at the request of the fire marshal it
includes one change to the state fire
code that was adopted after house bill
five uh 564 was finished so I had to
come in with an amendment it updates
through the
um
January meeting of the board of Fire
Control
and it also adds to the board of Fire
Control a fire protection engineer
the membership of the of the board of
Fire Control had been
created quite some time ago and now
there are fire protection engineers in
the state that would be willing to work
and the fire marshal believes their
service on the board will be useful so I
I support that
yes representative uh sorry
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for
thank you I'm just curious uh is that
fire protection engineer is that a new
uh designation for an officer well it's
newer than the board of Fire Control
which I believe is from the 60s
okay thank you I don't know how much
newer it to be
anyone else
yes representative Lucas
oh I have questions any Amendment but if
if you're someone else is Mr Timmy's
going to be speaking to you yeah
thank you very much representative thank
again Sean tomb in the State Fire
Marshal and so the uh the one amendment
that we addressed uh in January when we
adopted the 2018 codes we did a
comprehensive review
um food trucks Mobile Food units so food
trucks or trailers they added a
provision around gas uh certification so
a gas
um it seemed like a great idea so once a
year a gas technician would come in take
a look at the gas system on the mobile
food truck or or trailer make sure it's
safe and certify it well when it came to
practice everyone kind of scratched
their heads the industry and quite
frankly the fire service of how do we
really do that it seemed like a great
idea you just go into an inspection sign
off on it but where these trucks and
trailers are on the move a lot there's
some question about really truly what
standard should apply to the inspection
so so we look forward to the 2021
edition of the co we talked to many
other communities we talked to the gas
industry and realized that the the
direct Direction really is to put a gas
detector in the truck or the trailer and
forego the inspection the the benefit
would be the gas detector would be when
it's working would be sniffing for gas
essentially your gas leak all the time
it will alert the people in the trailer
to evacuate if there was a gas issue and
call 9-1-1 essentially so we we had a
public hearing at the board of Fire
Control everyone supported it it was
passed unanimously and I brought forward
for you for ratification
uh the second one I can speak to the the
as far as the fire protection engineer
goes
as representative McGuire indicated the
board of Fire Control has been around
for many many years I think some of the
earlier stuff is back in like 1947 it
does I think in the or 60s 70s there was
a couple of small changes there were a
very limited number of fire protection
engineers in the state
um 20 years ago when I became an
engineer I think there was I was the
fifth fire protection engineer that was
around in New Hampshire we probably have
a dozen plus of them now and I've had
several ask hey why don't we have a fire
protection engineer on the board of Fire
Control we work to protect people from
fire and the effects of fire do a lot of
work in the code industry as far as
building and fire codes this the board
of Fire Control serves an advisory
capacity to me in the office and also
very active in the code development
process and evaluation on the on the
fire code side so it seemed to make a
lot of sense and that's why we bring it
forward to you today for incorporation
on the board of Fire Control thank you
and happy to answer questions great are
there any questions yes representative
Gerhard thank you chairman hmm
concerning the Mobile Food detection
just this is gonna be a multi-part thing
if that's okay so just just ask a
question let him answer and then you can
ask so the annual the annual requirement
the inspection how much was that I've
been told that it varies by by
contractor essentially but I'm here as
about 150 dollars uh per per visit is
what I was told by at least two vendors
the previous correct okay so the
gas detection device how much is that
and how do you determine if those are
working is there still a yearly
inspection of that gas device now that's
what I'm curious about yeah so the
devices that we found were around 50 to
um and that they're intended to do like
a monthly test so they push the bunch
like we should test our smoke alarms on
our home so we'd push the button to test
it to make sure that they were
functioning
last follow-up follow-up so so are you
required to test these gas monitors in
these mobile food trucks the fire
service well do they have any is there
any way to actually enforce that that
they actually is such a device in these
units and that they actually are working
so typically uh the food trucks are are
licensed by the municipalities for their
for allowing on the Food Service side
and it comes with that typical fire a
quick fire inspection so I would say
that we the fire service would be able
to check to see the devices in place uh
and I I don't I can't I would I can't
say for sure whether every Fire official
in the state would physically touch them
but I would hope that they would look at
them at least make sure they're there
there's some requirements in the code
that talks about the the operator should
be testing them by depressing the button
thank you you're awesome yes
thank you Mr chairman
morning Marshall
uh so uh the the certification or
licensing that you referenced just a
moment ago with regard to uh
representative gerhardt's question uh
that inspection is done locally and that
food truck is is licensed for use in
that Community only or is that that
inspection and Licensing allow that food
truck to be on the uh the road anywhere
in the state of New Hampshire with with
uh or do they have to get licensed and
permitted in every community that they
sell in
thank you so I don't know that all the
specifics on the Food Service licensing
side there I will say there was a bill
last uh last session that talked about
trying to do a Statewide food truck
license that would help minimize the
requirements around licensing at each
different community so I think
I think I know there's some communities
that require licensure Concord I know
does from my previous time in Concord
Manchester does Nashua does
um but I don't know that you get into
the smaller communities there's not that
food truck license
what I'm concerned about is the
possibility that there could be kind of
a race to the bottom uh that somebody
would say well I I couldn't get licensed
uh by the I I have my food truck based
in let's say uh Community x uh I
couldn't get licensed there because they
know me I'm sloppy whatever you know and
so they get licensed in in community why
instead of community X because it's it's
easier to get you know past there uh and
and I'm concerned about the the safety
if there's not some kind of
a correct standard that's being applied
but for the safe operation of these
trucks which uh are great facilities
I've I've bought from them uh but uh but
to the degree that they have a lot of
not only food so sanitation is a real
important this issue but also uh if
they're using gas and propane and that
other kind of stuff their potential fire
hazard so I'm concerned about it could
you speak to that
so I think the uh
again the bill last session was trying
to address many of those comments that
you were speaking of about the different
Community standards and things like that
in the in the fire code Provisions uh as
they are today
the Fire official in a local community
would be able to go and make sure that
the the unit's safe and operating safely
under the provisions of the state fire
code
the amendment that we talk about really
just speaks to the a gas technician from
say Irving or uh
Rhymes or some other company that comes
in and does an inspection on that truck
for for the gas system uh and instead
puts that detector in so we can still
the fire officials can go in and still
make sure that the hood systems are
operating properly the the suppression
for the Hood is still there and
functioning as and has been inspected
that inspection requirement is still
there and we can make sure that the gas
detection device if this all gets
ratified is there and is in place but we
speaking to the Food Service side and
the sanitation and those things that
that's outside the purview of the state
fire code and I don't know
um unfortunately that still is gonna I
think very community community and this
this really doesn't address that at all
it wouldn't really be the appropriate
spot to address it in my opinion under
the fire code follow up do you have the
staff sufficient staff to carry out that
function this this specific this issue
that I'm raising you just said the
inspector can do this or the Fire
official can do this do you have
sufficient staff in your own
organization to handle that I would
always love more staff oh
much like anyone else right uh I would
say that we in conjunction with the
local fire departments it would be a
Cooperative effort between our office
and the local fire departments to get
this this task completed
um with the food trucks we our office
would not personally go out and do all
of these inspections of the trucks we
would rely on the help of the local
departments okay thank you
representative Graham
thank you uh Mr chair uh Marshall
perhaps maybe declare clean some of that
up
yeah I'll let you the opportunity to
discuss interoperability with many
different agencies it's not just a
standalone of the Fire Marshal's Office
so in the case of like let's use Nashua
as an example Nashua covers for public
health uh geographic area equally as
well anybody come into the city with the
food truck and everything has to be
inspected they do agree to spot
inspections they test the temperature of
the food how what is the temperature of
the hot water tank and just another
parameters and I don't think it's too
far of a reach that they would check the
uh the gas detectors equally as well as
well of what is required so there seems
to be a multi-tier level of inspections
because of this interoper
interoperability of many agencies with
the one focused goal to go with this
which you were great I would concur with
that I think though
the one thing to uh speak at the
representative Schmidt's comment is I
think there was an intent to have a
Statewide license to try to minimize the
changes and again this did this doesn't
contemplate that at all but
um you know I think maybe some for
future discussion if there's trying to
help the industry deal with a Statewide
license but as far as the locals helping
the locals our office working with them
the food the DHS DHHS food inspectors
work with the locals that there's a lot
of Cooperative work
and dealing with that to try to make
sure these units are safe
yes representative gold
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh I have a
constituent who raised the very concerns
we're talking about here so I want to
make sure I understand carefully what
this does is it changes the state rule
that we live in a very rural area in
Warner
um
so that the Warner fire chief will be
following this guideline and not require
the local gas person an additional
hundred and fifty dollars say inspection
is that correct am I understanding it
correctly yeah we're neighbors I think
so the uh the the Chief France would and
follow this provision uh when say the
Warner Fall Foliage Festival comes into
town and there's three or four food
trucks that show up he would just go and
make sure that that gas detector is
there and that's it and not say hey did
you have XYZ gas company do an
inspection and certification and look
for a certificate and that type of thing
thank you so much you're welcome
yes representative a bear
thank you
Mr chair
um
I guess as I read this as I've listened
to all of the testimonies I've checked
with Pelham fire department nobody sees
a problem with this this seems like this
just streamlines cleans a lot of things
up handles a few administrative things
gives some Freedom back to the food
trucks to have a monitor they don't have
to wait for an appointment for you guys
to show up
any I haven't heard any opposition at
all
thank you I I have not either I this
seems to be very welcomed I think if we
kept the current Provisions as it is in
the code today requiring the gas
certification by a company that's that's
the big concern for the food truck
industry
and quite frankly fire service we don't
any other questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
very much
is there anybody else who would like to
seeing none I will close the hearing
and I will hand the gavel back over to
so I'll move ought to pass on 0091
okay thank you so the
ought to pass on the amendment
is
by representative Schmidt seconded by
representative Gould
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh thank you ma'am sure so uh this is
the kind of uh service that we uh need
to support the building code review
board is uh is well staffed and well uh
attended I've been to their meetings in
the past and they are the gold standard
as far as I'm concerned so we've had the
testimony from the from the chair
chairman chairman but also from the fire
marshal so we should not delay on this
thank you okay representative
I just wanna on behalf of uh food truck
operators young people who are trying to
make a living thank you for reducing
costs without reducing risk
well without increasing risk
I felt sure that was what you meant all
right does anyone else wish to speak on
the amendment
okay seeing none the motion is to adopt
Amendment
zero zero nine one to House Bill 564 and
the clerk made by representative Schmidt
and the clerk and call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes representative Gerhard yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes represent goalie yes
representative schuette yes
representative O'Brien
don't be sipped out
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
I'd like to make a motion of uh ought to
pass as amended
thank
that ought to be ought to pass with
Amendment with Amendment right right
there you go it's not amended until the
house acts are true enough
with the men we'll carry them in the
middle of
it I understand
um right I I think these are you know
reasonable amendments the reason I
wanted to make the motion is that some
of them include the uh changes to the
grease trap rules that
were uh negotiated and and uh you know
Mr Sherman and others were involved when
we had the interim study uh
uh committee on those and I think these
are you know nothing's reduced safety
and it should they're just practical
things I think that uh
I am all set I think it was said well
said by representative leckis
no one else wish to cut to comment
question
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 564.
the and call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes clerk
vote Yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes
representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes 15 yay zero and a
the motion passes 15-0 is there any
objection to consent
seeing none will put this on consent I
don't always at first
and thank you but you close the
executive session the committee report
um
right
Upham Walker
the church
um
thank you
foreign
hearing on House Bill 617 and I call
Representative Gallagher
foreign
just for the record for people who
weren't with us previously um I'm Eric
Gallagher uh representing Concord Ward 6
which is Marriott County District 20 and
I am here
to introduce
house bill
an act prohibiting with limit exceptions
agencies from requiring use of
proprietary software and interactions
with the public
so
yeah this
I've been before this committee a few
times previously with some of my other
um
with some of my other
bills that
also came from the same bill that this
was split out from last term this is
another one that was part of last terms
software action which I was using as an
acronym for securing our freedom to
write and read everything
um
so yeah part of the criticism there was
I was trying to do too much in a single
bill
um
so
I took that criticism to heart and then
thus split up into
um
a bunch of different bills um so yeah
most of them are coming back here to
Edina but also one went to Judiciary one
went to criminal justice and then one is
going to be going to St e so that was a
question last time around is why isn't
this going to stnu well one of them is
um so this one is the part for um
what citizens can be required to use
um
when they interact with the state so
yeah it has a list of
it has a list of
um
situations
where it's supposed to
apply to
um you know saying including but not
limited to meaning there may be others I
forgot left out
um filing or payment of taxes remote
appearance for court proceedings taking
of standardized tests or completion of
course work by schools students applying
for or receiving other unemployment
benefits or other similar benefits
unless the government has determined
that proprietary software is the only
means available for the required
interaction
um
so
the thing is um
so this this is just on the end of the
public that it's applying to it's not
saying anything about what the
government itself can or can't use it's
just what it can require members of the
public to use so like when you're filing
your Medicaid redetermination
or um
or
food stamps redetermination or whatever
and need to upload proofs that they
should
accept it
from people who wish to only use free
and open source programs and don't wish
to use proprietary ones which should be
pretty easy since
um a lot of
documents are done in
PDF format which
um yeah is a portable format and most
uh most operating systems come with
built-in support for it and and
including list web browsers as well
um
the
of the
although you you just you do still see
um
you do still see some older websites
saying download Adobe Reader for this
PDF but um I I would think that those
should be removed since they're kind of
misleading since you don't actually need
to use Adobe Reader
um to view PDFs um
uh
um so
yeah this is just the
um one part about
um
so the the problem with proprietary
software is it's basically a way of
giving big tech companies control over
you and you know we're a very fiercely
independent state here where we don't
like other people telling us what to do
and
um
uh there are people who um want to be
able to Tinker with their software to
make changes with it so that they aren't
being tracked or take taken advantage of
by the company that makes them and they
should be able to interact with the
government just as easily as people
um
who
are okay with proprietary software and
um
so
yeah to give a few more examples
um
so
um the with school school work for
that that would just mean like if a
student wants to
type up their book report in LibreOffice
instead of word that
um
that the school would then accept it in
that format too which
the
the school wouldn't actually have to
change anything on their own end since
um
yeah this the same pro programs can open
it it would just
mean a change in policies
um so yeah um
one thing I've been ordered to is that
um
there is a new fiscal note online that
does not match the one that is printed
um in the um paper copy that was
available at the um
on the table there um I just like to
note a few issues with it
um so it still has the old title of this
bill on it um it says act prohibiting
with limited exception state agencies
from using proprietary software in
interactions with public
so yeah that was the old title but that
was not what my intent was I asked OLS
to change it because that was a major
sticking point of
last year's bill was that
the government can't just go and change
all of the software it is itself that
easily so um
yeah um I think that there has been kind
of a misunderstanding here where
um
where the fiscal note is based on
the idea that
um
the government would have to replace its
own software
which is not what this bill does
um it also mentions stuff about
State websites the state websites part
was a separate bill
um it was one of the previous bills um
that
um excuse me could you just concentrate
on this bill
um well yeah so I'm saying that the
fiscal note here I mentioning it because
the fiscal note attached to this bill is
referring to a previous bill that is not
this bill so I would just oh thank you
so so we should not take it we should
take it with a grain of salt yes
so
um
so yeah basically yeah just take the
fiscal nut with a grain of salt I have
so I managed to uh round up a few other
free software supporters to come testify
with me today so they can go more into
depth on that um but for now I'll take
any questions okay
thank you uh representative lekkis and
then a bear thank you so uh I need some
help you know better understanding what
you're trying to get at in this bill
about so this is requiring people to run
proprietary software we dealt earlier
with JavaScript are there any
applications that the states requiring
people proprietary applications to
States for people requiring people to
run on their computers to access the
websites or
are there others dealing with uh you
know document formats I mean are the
schools literally requiring it be word I
actually use LibreOffice and I'm
familiar with yeah it can generate PDFs
so you know what
what are cases where you know that the
government is requiring people to run a
proprietary applications on their
computers well I mean I'm just
remembering for when I was in school
some teachers were very specific of you
must submit in a DOT DOC format and when
when they were teaching um
what yeah when they were teaching in the
tech ed classes it was on how to use
this proprietary software specifically
which we were required to was what was
one of our requirements for something we
had to take as part of our curriculum
right
um follow-up follow-up yeah so I I mean
some of those formats like dot doc
LibreOffice will generate I believe so
will various other free or open software
so what I'm trying to understand is Are
there specific examples today
where interacting with the government
requires you to run a proprietary
software on your own system other than
the JavaScript we dealt with earlier
um
well I think
for when there is a remote attendance
option for things
um
that remote attendance option is usually
Zoom which may be free cost wise but is
still proprietary software so I would
think that in
cases where like say yeah if you have to
if the physical court is closed and you
have to appear
remotely that there should be a free
software
um alternative to zoom that people can
use to appear in court
one more follow-up okay that one
actually that makes sense are there any
others that you're aware of
um
well
those are the main ones I want to touch
on myself I'm was talking with some of
the other testifiers who are going to
have their own examples
um so yeah not I'm going to try not to
Gallagher thank you very much for your
testimony if you could give us a few
more examples of my colleague
representative lekkis was just remarking
but if we could do
more of an understanding citizen of a
bear he said he doesn't have any more
examples he's waiting for the other
people to testify so if you could defer
your question thank you
just representative Dolan and gerhardt
chair the the issue that that I'm
concerned about it something like the
state requires rooms and meal Stacks to
be paid
um by users of of that of those
utilities and you have to you have to
log on to the state system
proprietary software that the state has
in order to pay the rooms in Middlesex
so how what would this
legislation do to people that that want
to log on and do and pay those those uh
those fees and would it require the
state to incur a lot more costs to be
able to accommodate all kinds of uh
individual software
um so
I have not uh paid the rooms and meals
tax myself personally so I'm not too
familiar with
um
but
yeah um
Well yeah if it's a web-based interface
then I think that would fit more under
the one about JavaScript that
um
I introduced previously but if it's not
a web-based interface well then I I
guess I would need to
look at that in more detail to be able
okay thank you virtually bear
thank you madam chair
regarding the language in here required
to use proprietary software for any
interaction with the government in just
playing off of this for one second when
you log your Miles when you walk in in
the morning would that include that you
wouldn't have to do that
um
so
I I think that the kiosks where uh you
log your miles should be built with
um free software I think
yeah I think that there should be an
alternative
um like we were able to file mileage
perfectly fine previously with a paper
alternative and
um
so yeah I think I think if
yeah if it's impossible I if it's
impossible to provide a free software
alternative to the mileage kiosk
sign-ins then I think
um
the solution should be
to continue to provide a paper
alternative
thank you representative uh thank you
actually that my I was making an
assumption may be incorrect and you can
correct me that this
I'm sorry I misrepresentative Gerhart
that
um
that this was your concern and what this
bill was about was being required to run
proprietary software on your own
equipment your phone your computer or
whatever whereas the kiosk that's not
the case so I mean if my question is if
you view this as applying that
expansively would that also apply let's
say to the uh the parking meter things
where you put your card or money in and
you get a ticket to put on your on your
um
yeah I I guess that's a good point that
um I guess could
use some
um
let me look at the
language
um
I mean I I think
um in the cases where it's not the
user's own computer that that would fall
um under the
um exception for unless the agency has
determined that proprietary software is
the only means available
um since yeah that that only means
available because they
are the ones who put it there so um okay
thank you
excuse me
what
your main motivation here is it more
concerned about corporations the tech
corporations are more concerned about
the government who you worry about this
information falling into the hands of
exactly
um
so
well it's
it's kind of the overlap between the two
that that's
worrying um going on here um I I think
that the government should not be
depending on
private corporations
um to do its
to function
um I think that
it should be able to do its own business
in a free and open manner that the
citizens who uh who control the
government you know of the People by the
people for the people
um decide upon
rather than
um
rather than having corporations make
those decisions for the government
all right thank you
good morning ladies and gentlemen Madam
chair
uh I look at this bill as an opportunity
for people citizens to have access to
the government in all forms
is not to say What pro software the
government should be using in their
day-to-day and interactions with each
other
I can give you a couple of examples
public libraries oftentimes have
computers in them for people that do not
have access to the internet do not have
access to computers
they can go into the library they can
use a computer perhaps to look for jobs
perhaps to interact with the government
in some way shape or form
if you require these libraries to buy
proprietary software
then that puts a fiscal issue for them
as well as a license management issue
that typically doesn't happen when you
use free software
so there is one example to allow
libraries to use software and rely to
standards which we should be using
libraries are not the subject of this
bill we're talking about State agencies
yes ma'am okay so could a library is not
a state agency that is true okay thank
you however the states
using software that forces a citizen to
use proprietary software when they're
only access to it is through a public
library is a state problem
ah thank you I'm glad I could clarify
that
the other thing about this bill is a an
example of schools
so he can high school has kind of
concentrated themselves on using Apple
software
and an apple networking environment
if the school says well in order to go
here you have to buy an Apple computer
because that interacts with it and that
keeps people from buying a Microsoft
based computer or keeps people from
buying using free software in order to
interact with the network that is not
also a good thing
another example of this is and and what
I would like to to say too especially
with the fiscal impact statement of the
online copy of this
this is a bill that should be looking
towards the future and not the past
so when you create a new RFP for a new
software that you're going to put as a
state system you should say in that RFP
that it needs to be able to operate with
free software into citizens hands
and again I'm not saying anything about
the interactions of of systems that are
used by employees of the state
I'm talking about software that causes
an interaction of a citizen with the
state
I think that's about it thank you very
much for listening to me oh one more
thing the fiscal impact of implementing
this should be very minimal I don't have
any idea as to the numbers of systems
that might be affected however when you
go for an upgrade to that system or when
you go for extending the licenses of
those systems you could make this a
requirement of the company that produced
that system and that's what I think is
most important thank you thank you are
I think my guy who was testifying walked
away
oh
that's okay we're gonna drag you back
um
what I'm running through my mind I'm I'm
intrigued by this bill and interested
and
I'm looking for some examples as I'm
running this through my mind
also to make sure that we don't trip a
Wire by having something that closes a
door on us either right
um
so I started to say like the the zoom
meetings the teams meeting I I've been
in those situations where somebody sent
you an invite and it's on
let's say it's on teams
I'm gonna have to log in I gotta go
figure out I Gotta Go download the damn
thing and then get get that going right
so I get where we're going but I'm
looking for some some examples so I'm
thinking
unemployment
um
I'm thinking when I have to upload a
picture of a certificate or something
that it's got to be in a JPG I've got it
in a PNG
IGS right nope that doesn't work that
doesn't work so I was looking for some
good solid examples thank you sorry for
the long question
well we'll take the first one uh jitsi
is a piece of software that allows you
to do a video conference and it works
under any w3c compliant browser so you
can do it on edge you can do it on
um on Firefox you can do it on Chrome
and that would be an alternative to
using Zoom
um you don't need to log in you don't
need to have an account you can just
fire it up
um
so that would be one example
uh
I have certain doctors forums I work
with that they don't accept a JPEG and
they don't accept a PNG and they don't
accept you know they only accept a PDF
that's fine because I know how to
generate those but it's often awkward
because the input that I have is in that
format
so you know again we should be looking
to be expansive and to try and take in
as many types of things as possible as
opposed to being restrictive
did I answer your question
okay
any other questions
I don't see any thank you representative
assignment sorry you said jitsy is that
correct Gypsy can you spell that for me
j-i-t-s-i
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Dennis Goddard I
live in Hopkinton I wanted to say just a
couple of um points related to the bill
I think it's already been
noted that the the fiscal note is
probably way off base
um
I I would say what this bill is kind of
asking for is an accessible entrance
to a building for those of us that Maybe
don't want to use the normal one
the bill for that work I would expect to
be making an accessible entrance maybe a
ramp maybe a doorknob I wouldn't expect
the bill to be we have to replace the
house
okay you don't need a new building
and so by that analogy I want to talk
about what we're talking about here um
I'm one of the people that um
worked back in Silicon Valley during the
late 90s and early Arts I'm one of the
army of people that worked so damn hard
during that time to make it possible to
have the web that we now have for those
who don't remember there was a war I
mean it was bad it was brutal
um where some companies wanted to
dictate exactly how the web was going to
work and not necessarily publish the
details
and really what made the internet
explode and happen and useful for
everybody was that it's uh what we call
Open Standards
you could go to any place and read like
an academic paper here's exactly how
it's supposed to work here's my computer
and the data it's going to send to you
and your computer the data we expected
to get back and
the the way to exchange the data and
it's all laid out and anyone can read it
and write their own the idea was you
make your own best implementation you
might have a proprietary server that's
better
um but you're talking the same language
that anyone else can talk that's how we
made the internet where all our
computers could talk together
um you all mostly will be familiar with
HTML which anyone can like look at HTML
and like if you've done a little reading
you can understand there's books you can
read or whatever you can look up okay if
I have an angle bracket and a b and then
an end angle bracket means there's going
to be bold okay it's not like a secret
um
one more example just to make it a
little more clear I think for folks most
people are familiar with Microsoft Word
Microsoft Office
um
starting some years ago you may have
noticed that the extension changed when
you save the file sometimes it used to
be say a PPT file or a dot doc file now
you see it's a DOT pptx or a DOT docx
and you go whatever seems to work the X
actually stands for XML which is kind of
like an HTML thing long and short of it
is it's an open standard it's published
it's out there any one that's like in
the field can easily see oh okay this is
the format of the document here's how I
read it here's what that stuff means is
this is bold this is italic here's a
paragraph
Etc
and that's what makes it possible for
open source code to do stuff like open
Word documents read them and send you a
Word document as far as you know yeah
and so again what this what I read this
Bill is saying is what I think is
motivating some of us to show up here
today
um is that we're the sort of honestly
conscientious objectors
um
look I I work in in again the it field I
do a lot with security lately I work at
a very large database company as it
turns out probably the kind of company
that most of the people behind me do not
want to do business with but yet here I
am reading a paycheck
um at least I'm not here running a
paycheck but I mean I I'm employed there
but the point is one thing I've learned
keeping data safe
is that the internet and if there's one
thing I I want to impart to you today
whether it's open source or not the
internet is an adversarial environment
it's a war and it has been for at least
a decade and it's not even two sides it
it's not like um good guys and bad guys
it's just an open chaos field and it's
non-stop 24 7. it's on every Internet
connected device that you own most of
the time you don't see it because
there's nothing that would show it to
you because it's not going to help you
to see how many times you're trying to
be hacked
every day
um that's not so much the point well the
point is that those of us who are really
involved with with this stuff tend to be
those who are most concerned
um
I again being involved very deeply in in
the space of large data
um
I I don't use Windows at home no way my
employer gives me a phone
um that they have their proprietary
software on so I can you know work
remotely and stuff but my personal phone
is neither uh Google nor Apple thank you
very much it's an open Hardware an Open
Source phone with switches on it that I
can flick that say like it's physically
disconnected the camera is not on
um
you know
I realize that's not everybody and
certainly those of us in a weird little
I'll call it religious minority for the
sake of a better term and I want to come
back to that momentarily
um we're not trying to make everyone
comport to our particular weirdness
um but
I do think that it's fairly well
established and the way that we want to
have our civil society um that there are
rights of conscience that are really at
the base even of the religious freedoms
that um those in the faith-based
community enjoy they're all based in
these rights of conscience not all of
which are specifically about
um faith we have also bits in our
constitution about things like those who
are really scrupulous in avoiding the
use of weapons not being conscripted in
a war
I use that war analogy for a reason
um I'm very scrupulous in my personal
life I know some people aren't you know
we're the Quakers it's cool you don't
have to come into our meetings
um but I I don't use this stuff I don't
want to I understand how big the machine
is and how little it's in control and
how little faith I have that any
government is going to get it under
control how little uh how much I know
how many governments and
uh Oregon companies are
far too involved in each other so here
here's what I want to leave you with
um
what we're asking for is just to make
sure that when government puts something
up and it doesn't have to retroactively
immediately be everything that we've
ever done but like can we let
towns know can we let the state
government know you're about to roll out
some piece of whatever
um make sure it's Open Standards right
if you're going to stream something and
maybe you feel it necessary to stream it
you know look at open source options if
they're available at all don't don't
make us
use them um you know sometimes there's
there's cheap ways to do stuff like you
want to stream stuff on YouTube and it's
really easy for most people there are
little things you can do I I personally
set up what's called an invidious
instance for my uh family and friends
um that lets me use YouTube without
YouTube collecting the data of those who
use YouTube
um
again it it's really not about
finding every piece of proprietary
software and getting rid of it it's just
making sure that government doesn't
require me as a taxpayer as a user to
install some piece of software use a
piece of software that was created by an
organization that won't show me the
source code or doesn't publish its
interfaces so that others
um
can can play in the same space
um that that's why one last thing I'm
sorry web browsers web browsers this was
the whole War I was talking about in the
90s and early Arts um the reason that it
doesn't matter what web browser you use
when you go to any website that was a
big thing if you remember the little
icon you'd see on some websites like
this site best viewed in any browser
because at the time Microsoft really
wanted you to use the Microsoft
um Internet Explorer browser that they
actually just got that they just
de-supported which is one of the reasons
that some of us are really concerned
about these things Open Standards don't
go away because some company isn't
finding them profitable anymore
um so yeah please do don't take this to
be you have to get rid of the whole
house please take this to be for those
of us are really scrupulous about these
things we'd like an alternate entrance
or maybe the default entrance to be one
that everyone
can use with where the standards are
my my own twin brother was in the
military he was saying actually the
government runs Linux on the computers
that control the missiles because he was
over in hungry messing with that so I
understand the concept and personally I
use Linux myself on home and lineage on
some of my cell phones but what I'm
concerned about is somebody that is also
on the committee that was talking about
the fact is no there's no support or
upkeep or upgrades to this open source
software how do you deal with that so
the state says we're going to have this
system doing this all of a sudden you
guys get bored you move on to a new
project nobody's up keeping the thing
what do we do I mentioned that my
company is responsible for some of the
largest databases in the world the ones
that have all of your cell phone records
all of your financial records um the big
companies choose our database to store
your stuff in and they store their stuff
on Linux servers most of most of them
and my team are 24 7 Around the Clock in
some uh time zone it's it's noon
somewhere
um and they're helping our customers fix
any problem they have uh in in short the
assertion that there isn't support is in
fact a not correct one there are many
many in fact there is a diversity
of consultancies that are more than
willing to provide support to open
source software and that diversity and
and ecosystem and dare I say capitalist
incentive is there because
uh the standards are open and uh people
can compete on providing good service at
a good price
thank you thank you representative
thank you hey Dennis good to see you
again uh I understand the philosophical
or as you put it religious View and I'm
sort of part of that religion although
probably not as Orthodox
um as you but to help us with this bill
I mean statute has to be pretty specific
we can't we're not generally writing
General philosophy so it's kind of
related to the questions I asked before
um we had the example of Zoom we had the
example of schools maybe requiring
certain Hardware I get that
um
but some of these uh formats at this
point I don't know of any that you know
open source software won't generate as
far as uploading documents for example
I'm looking for and this also is to help
us
make some assessment of the fiscal note
if it makes any sense and so the
question is what examples are there
where people are required to use
proprietary software to interact with
the state government sure um you've
opened a very
easy and interesting one
um you know my children had to use zoom
uh in in their schools I wasn't thrilled
about it but there you go
um
I fear a time when my uh whether it's my
town or the state of New Hampshire tells
me that to either pay a tax or pay a
ticket or pay for the parking whatever
that I can download an app that works in
either apple or iOS
it's almost like being able to vote both
Republican and Democrat and asking why
there's any problem
um
but I definitely hear the concern
I I
you know I'm very grateful that you guys
are professional at the use of language
to craft
um desired policy outcome because I I'm
not sure how to go about doing so
um in a way I want examples
um but in a way you know
um but but I hear the need for
specificity
um
so I think that there clearly needs to
be some language to clarify things for
the the general audience and for the um
for the organizations and state
organizations that will have to
determine whether they're compliant or
what they have to do
my personal opinion is that there ought
to be a study committee frankly but I'm
not a legislator but I I will say I
could tell your lack of Orthodoxy
um right away just from the general
um yeah I mean
I don't know if we can whatever happens
to this bill I'll be glad to work with
you and Rob Gallagher to maybe talk
about options and get ideas anyway thank
you okay
president Dolan and the neighbor
thank you madam chair I
as I'm concerned about Costa government
and so my question is go back to the
what I raised earlier about
interfacing with the with the
proprietary software that the state has
to pay your rooms and meal stacks
it's not hard to to
consider that
if I just tore off a piece of paper and
said I don't want to interface with your
software so I'm going to submit a piece
of paper with my end scratch on it that
it would cost the government a lot more
money to process that piece of paper
than to
allow the auditor to have the individual
put these the information into the to
the proprietary software what do what do
we do in in uh in that case in a
situation how do we prevent the cost of
government growing in order to
accommodate
what's being suggested sure thank you
for the question and as a person who
might you know one of the teams my team
and sometimes I have to do is we we
actually process tickets they're they're
not for parking fines that someone has a
problem and there's a ticket and it
comes to us and the ones that cost us
the most are those weird one-off ones
right if if there was a standardization
we could process 10 000 times the amount
but like it's the weird one-offs that
cost you right it's like very much hear
what you're saying about
the guy with the strange request and the
torn off piece of paper fortunately I
think like like all analogies this one
breaks down at a certain point
um I think the key here is not
necessarily to say that anyone can use
any method that they want to use any
branch of government I mean we're not
saying you can come in and speak Swahili
for some purpose and expect that the
person behind the counter is going to
have to help you but rather that when
government is setting up these
interfaces or setting up these systems
typically it's not at all a uh
a confusing or a Shades of Gray kind of
thing typically you've either got a
a check box that a provider or a company
will say is well you know it conforms to
you know whatever open standard SSL V3
or HTML5
Etc
um which is why for example right our
state government last I checked uh we're
using IIs
information Microsoft's web server for a
lot of things I don't have to use
Microsoft in my browser because we're
talking this common HTML language
um and so we're not saying that we can
literally go in and say I want to speak
a different language but that as long as
your browser is set up so that HTML is
the lingua Franca and it's the published
HTML that we all mean we say HTML then
then there's no issue as opposed to well
you have to use the Microsoft browser to
go to this web page because that's the
deal
foreign
thank you madam chair so back to your
original opening comment about we want
to replace the door not the building
analogy
would it behoove us to have the bill
State something that all new systems and
renovated systems would be certified
through our I.T officer also sitting in
the panel here today
to ensure that it's open source would
that cover
thank you uh thank you for the question
I I think that would go I I would love
that I think it would go a little
farther than our choir I think a very
Central piece of of my personal
religiousness I never turned down a
small piece of cake
um so
um if language is emitted so that um
open source should be you know
considered for any new systems that's
great
um and again I I think an important part
of of this resubmit is that it doesn't
mandate that the sort that the state use
open source it could very well be a
closed Source fully proprietary you know
owned and maintained by Microsoft or
whoever
um but that those interfaces to the
public
that those be Open Standards open
published standards
thank you
all right
um so let me give me a I'm so I'm
Christopher Wade uh from Keene New
Hampshire
um I I own a small well fairly small
business
um that uh basically we sell hardware
and I'm in the free software uh I do
free software development um and I fund
free software development
um a little bit about me
um so I I probably have the most
expertise in terms of uh dealing with
non-technical users and free software
systems as my company is the the leading
the leading retailer of computers
basically uh to
the world effectively
um and accessories for that matter
um so uh one of the things I want to
make a few comments on what is actually
if you're gonna if you're gonna have
something amended or changed here
um it doesn't it's not necessarily as
far as this bill is concerned that
everything be open source or free
software
um what matters is actually that the
formats and the apis uh be open such
that users can interact with the
government
um and ensure that the users can
interact all users can interact with the
government so
um
so this is this is I want to talk a
little about the costs here real quick
so this isn't really any different than
what's already uh already available the
government's already doing in terms of
accommodating people with disabilities
um you know if if there's a program to
say for example submit and I don't know
enough about this specifically but
submit uh rooms and meals tax to the
government they already are going to
have to offer something for somebody
who's disabled so this is not they
shouldn't really have any substantial
costs uh all it does is it effectively
apply this what what people with
disabilities have already got to
everybody
um
oh
so um one of the things about people
were talking about security so the
security thing the only people who are
saying that there's like an issue there
I think are people who don't understand
free software and how it's developed so
canonical and IBM are basically two
companies that put out the leading
Enterprise uh distribution there's some
others but leading Enterprise
distributions for for Linux and free
software and gnu and basically uh the
way the way it works in the free
software world is they're these
basically companies are distributions
and they maintain the software so you
get security updates you can get 10 to
12 years of security updates for
basically almost any application that
you would want to run on your system and
this doesn't matter if it's your web
browser like Firefox or you know Apache
web server or whatever
um so it's not it's not really it's not
like in Windows where it is the other
thing it's not like in Windows or with
apple you know if apple or Microsoft
discontinues something you know you're
that's it there's nothing you can do
about it if I'm if I am looking at
options this is one of the great things
about the free market and free software
is there's actually competition in the
market so if I'm looking at I don't know
let's I'm trying to think of another
example Debian Debian uh is they've got
sort of official support maintained for
five years with their distribution well
their distribution has most of the same
software that IBM's distribution and
canonicals distribution have
um but the difference is their support
though how long that support lasts for
security updates it's different so if
you need something that's a long-term
supported distribution you'd want to
look at canonical or if you even need
longer support you'd want to look at
something like red hat Enterprise links
from IBM
all right um so my main concern though
here today is actually uh non-technical
users it's usually non-technical users
who get stumped by you know issues when
it comes to interfacing with governments
and schools and things like that
um basically what this would do is it
would just make it easier for people to
uh when when problems occurred uh it
makes it easier for somebody to say hey
wait a minute teach you got to give me
another way to submit my my my paper
that I might have to submit maybe that's
on maybe physically hand them a paper or
um you know submit it in an ODT file it
doesn't actually the bill doesn't it's
it's saying mandate right they can't
mandate these proprietary software so
that doesn't mean you know it doesn't
mean it even has to be it just means
there has to be they have to offer you
another option if you have an issue
um
so one of the other things is without
it's important for security from like an
end user standpoint uh that their source
is available and
it you know a lot of people here are
talking about it from like a technical
standpoint but this is actually more
concerning to me from an end user
standpoint Because unless free software
developers can look at the source code
and not just the people who wrote it you
can't really even begin to have a
conversation about security
um and you can't begin to have a secure
system one of the things you'll never
hear is a new Linux user saying oh I was
infected by you know malware X or you
know virus X you just you can't get
infected when the distribution when you
have a distribution you've got your
security updates up to date there is no
antivirus for Linux except for antivirus
that stands for Windows viruses
um and this is something I think people
fail to understand about security like
the general population it's it's it's
because the way proprietary software is
developed that we have security issues
it's not that there aren't bugs in free
software there are but they're fixed and
they can be fixed and there's
competition in the market that ensures
those security issues get resolved
excuse me sir I think you're you're
drifting from the bill in question could
you wrap it up all the points I've made
were specifically related to what we've
talked about
um that were asked questions
um
so uh the other thing I want to point
out is that proprietary software is
actually already undermining people's
with people with disabilities access to
government services
um just as an example
um so I'm actually going to give you an
example for people who are getting like
welfare and things like that um that
people wanted an example of where this
actually hinders people today
um and that is with what welfare
basically I'm not sure exactly it's true
at the state level or not but I know I
believe it's at least at the federal
level
um there are some benefits and I'm not
sure specifically welfare specifically
it might be more like Social Security
but there are certain things that you
have to fill out and it has to be with
Adobe Reader it cannot be with a free
PDF reader
um so that's that's a good example
um Court ordering monitoring software is
another good example and again I I'm not
I'm not that familiar with state New
Hampshire specifically I only know
people who have had this happen at the
federal level but it's not unlikely that
their State uh there's something state
level equivalent of uh monitoring
software
um devices like parking meters are often
mechanical not and they're not dependent
on software so it's not actually a
software problem in most cases
um and this bill probably would have no
effect on it as far as I can see
um
so another example of where government
forces
users to run proprietary software on
their own computer is submitting
okay something else that's important to
note is
a end user license agreement is
something that you agree to Simply by
using the software
um it's really messed up that government
can tell you that you have to agree to
Microsoft's terms in order to use
Microsoft Word or Microsoft Windows or
anything like that
um you're you're effectively forcing
somebody to agree to a contract that
that they don't necessarily agree to
um I'm not even sure how that that's
legal but
anyway
um yeah so that's that's what I have to
say on there if anybody has any
questions I'll be more than happy to
representative gerhardt all right thank
you madam chair you said that there are
free market pressures on open source
developers to maintain their software
and to keep it free what yes when I when
I downloaded Linux it was free so what
free market where's the motive oh yeah
so that's pretty simple
um
so there's competition in the
marketplace there's different versions
of Linux and it may be that your version
of Linux I don't know what do you do
what you do you know what you what
you're currently cinnamon okay one
expand I'm assuming um so Linux Mint has
support for three to five years
basically you're not going to get
security updates for more than five
years you have to move off of it after
five years if you want uh if you want to
have security updates for say you know
10 years or 12 years you would have to
use something like red hat Enterprise
Linux or
um uh I'm trying to think some of the
others uh uh Ubuntu that's fine I just
one follow-up and then thank you and
those are Commercial Services that
they're offering you understand those
those ladder Commercial Services that
you're talking about are those are those
open source themselves yeah
I just don't see how you can sell
something when it's open source the
information's out there okay um so
anyway I'm good I'm good okay you could
buy all the parts for a car and build it
yourself or you could pay somebody for a
thank you very much I don't see any
other questions
thank you
so I am Ben
I'm a computer science PhD student at
Dartmouth College uh and my area of
research is cyber security
uh with free software you can see how it
works and with proprietary software you
can't so that's like not being able to
pop the hood of your car uh so with zoom
uh they've had a really bad privacy and
security track record uh they claimed to
use end-to-end encryption and then it
turned out that they were
lying about that and that really they
meant there's only encryption between
the users and zoom's servers which is
employed almost almost every web service
works that way so that's like every scam
on the Internet is end-to-end encrypted
if that's your definition of end-to-end
encrypt
um free software doesn't have this issue
because public code can be independently
verified
so that's why I think I should not be
made to use proprietary software in my
interactions with the government
thank you that's well stated any
questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
te
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record I am Dennis
Goulet I'm the commissioner for the
Department of information technology
which is responsible for it for the
executive branch of government in New
Hampshire
um first of all I want to start out with
a little scope
um because you know there's been some
questions on
um the fiscal note and how it was
developed and whether it's accurate or
not so I want to touch on that a little
bit
um
basically what I'm you know one of the
implications was the um that the um
there was some confusion relative to the
websites and and applications that are
public facing so I want to touch on that
just for a minute it turns out that I
didn't consider our websites in scope
for either this bill or House Bill 327
which is a JavaScript bill because we're
running we're presently running 96
um
executive branch websites and
most of those have already been moved
over to our new platform which is
actually running an open source and and
didn't have the JavaScript problem nor
nor do we consider it yeah we consider
it compliant with the language of this
bill so there's no website work that we
considered having to be funded or done
because we're already doing that work on
an existing project that's moving all
the executive branch websites into the
Drupal platform managed by Aqua on our
behalf so I consider that something that
I didn't include in the scope of either
of those bills and what we did include
though is we looked at how many
applications we had in the executive
branch of government which was
um actually I'm looking it up now we had
670 executive branch applications that
we looked at these are these are not
little things that we we kind of made
sure it was bigger than a bread box
before we considered it and up to 271 of
those are public facing and then we said
you know you you have to make
assumptions on a fiscal note like this
so we we made an assumption that we
would have to address 90 percent of
those so so that's you know and then we
looked at broke up the applications into
small medium large and extra large and
uh you may recall that it was a range of
costs in House Bill 327 we put a single
cost per application size in this bill
because we actually have a lot of recent
experience acquiring applications so we
had a decent idea of how much it would
cost to implement an app for example the
Department of Revenue uh their new
Revenue information system which is
specifically called out in this language
cost a little over 30 million dollars to
implement over a three year period so so
we had some reasonable good numbers
so I would submit that neither did I
misunderstand nor is the the fiscal note
um far off
um I'd also like to address the the
concept of doing it all now versus doing
it incrementally going forward uh which
you know certainly would be the right
way to do any large change like that
we're considering here
um one of the factors is and we talked
about this before was there's you know
state government applications are very
specific there isn't a huge Market out
there for the a lot of these 271 apps
are very unique to that particular thing
that we're doing so when we go out and
acquire there A lot of times there are
Niche companies who are developing this
like the revenue system for example it's
a niche company they do revenue and they
do driver license that's all they do
there's no open source alternative for
that so what we would my assumptions
under the fiscal note and those would
apply whether we did it you know set up
over A Five-Year Plan to turn everything
over but we just did everything upon
reacquiring or re-bidding is that we
would have to develop in an open source
context
most of the apps we were acquiring if we
did require that we use open source for
that so we'd create an open source info
ecosystem we would have to hire
developers or contract with developers
to do that and we'd operate in that
manner so that those were the
assumptions in my bill and you know I
would stand by the the cost whether it
was compressed into a five-year period
or done over a 30-year period very
expensive uh to to do this
now I'd like to address you know we
actually do consider open source
every time we're looking at something in
fact I just gave an example of our
websites when we went out and said all
right we need a platform to develop and
host our web stuff we picked Drupal
because it was a really great
alternative there were companies out
there that would help us manage it so I
could you know that was 96 websites I
support them with three people
three people in my staff so it's a
pretty efficient setup with that so
that's working well we have over a
thousand Linux servers running
um almost all of our major State
applications including the uh including
the integrated eligibility system that
HHS operates called New Heights that has
a citizen-facing component which is
called New Hampshire easy
um you know so we're our learning
management system is open source so when
there's a good alternative that already
exists
you know I'm all for it what the reason
I'm opposed to the language of the bill
and and focusing simply on open sources
it's it's just not practical we would
have to the time to value for new
applications if we have to develop them
versus you know purchase an 85 or 90
solution off the shelf is you know is
too far out it actually would constrain
our ability to improve citizen service
and again we'd have to be contracting
with more developers than we do today
representative Prada thank you I'm sorry
I don't have the fiscal note so can you
tell me the cost on the fiscal note uh
uh
right now I think it was
um I had um put it at it's about a
little over 320 million for each year 24
25 and 26. that's assuming we would
churn over those 271 applications in
five years so I actually if you look at
my original the worksheet that I did for
myself it's a Five-Year Plan very tight
Five-Year Plan that would be you know
that about a little over 320 320 million
per year
thank you representative blackis yeah
just uh so I understand the assumptions
you made concerning the interpretation
of this when you do the physical note
were you assuming that this would
require
that any public-facing application would
have to have zero proprietary software
um I assume 90 of those public facing
applications not websites would have no
no propriety in other words you know I I
considered we'd have to create an open
source entity inside the state and
operate that and you know because there
there isn't such a thing existing today
and then our and our anybody we
contracted with or our own developers
would have to operate in that context
follow-up follow-up just to clarify we
said 90 I mean you'd you'd have to get
it down to the point where no more than
10 percent was proprietary or you're
saying there's some percentage now or
well I I was interpreting you know this
is an assumption I made which I could be
incorrect but I said the the language of
the bill said um you know all but a very
few
so I just said all right 90 you know we
could say 95 we could say 85 you know
I'm you know all right thank you yeah
thank you madam chair
would this be considered a very
labor-intensive activity more so than
physical infrastructure or what would be
the main cost here well um well the um
the biggest cost I think would be
there's two you know two two costs free
software isn't free um in fact when I
pay for software the largest cost isn't
the actually the acquisition of the
software it's the implementation of the
software and that would be true for open
source as well so if if you say I want
to change from system a to system B
even even if I'm not paying for the
software for system B there's a large
cost of turning over both opportunity
costs inside the organization I.E taking
work away from doing your day job and
moving that system as well as you know
any Services you might need wrap around
follow please thank you madam chair
my my question is more concerning there
seems to be an activist Community that's
very concerned about this would there be
any way for these activists to be active
and actually implementing this and then
cutting the state's cost in it or is
this sensitive data that's whatever well
it it absolutely is in fact a lot of my
roles require
um you know in fact when I if I bring on
new employees uh depending on where
they're working there's certain you know
Hoops we have to jump through before I
can even hire them because of the type
of data that's being used most
particularly in revenue and Department
of Safety
good afternoon baber thank you madam
chair I have a question for you are we
continuing this later is it does it go
to Executive does it go to
subcommittee obviously there's so many
more questions thank you
um I'm not sure I don't think we should
consider this a graduate course and and
software but um we'll I don't think
we'll be exacting it right away
uh Mr Goulet I have a question as I am
not a software engineer so first but as
I read the bill it simply says that if
I'm on my computer using
Linux and open office or whatever
can I access these systems and I have to
say that I have been able to for example
file my interest in dividends tax
without using proprietary software and
I'm sure that their system is
so what is
isn't it only the interface that this
bill affects well or am I confused well
I think as written it's more expansive
um but
um you know certainly we do it's
certainly not our intent to require
people to use open source software
sometimes I think that uh it there may
be applications we have particularly
older ones because we have applications
everything from brand new right now to
35 years old and and what we're seeing
is the ones the older ones tend to be
more restrictive because technology
wasn't as good 35 years ago as it is
when you were talking about having a
open source environment I mean would you
able to check it out by using an open
source web browser and say can I can I
do what I need to do on this software
regardless of what's inside the Black
Box yeah
and that would be an event I think that
would be a piece but that particular
valuation would be a bit by bit on the
271 apps as we re-procure them if we
chose to go forward that way okay thank
you
anyone else
yes represent gold
thank you madam chair hello hi uh and
thank you for taking my question so
I just want to ensure that the 300
million is that what the figure was you
gave
320 and those formulatically done and
I'd be happy to take anybody that
desires to go through my my my model
through it in detail yeah no I trust you
in terms of the scope you were talking
about so as I and thank you madam chair
for your question that was my question
as I understand it what we're talking
about is going forward ensuring that any
new programs that are developed will
accept open source created documents
formats would that reduce the 300
million dollar costs to put that clause
in your bids for software development in
the future that's a that's a completely
different animal in my in my estimation
it would
um it would cause a reevaluation and
we'd have to look at what the specific
we're always looking for a
85 or 90 solution to get to that hundred
is a lot more expensive than the 85 or
90. and um when we're talking about
um okay we're going to have systems that
will accept any kind of document format
things like that
that that adds quite a bit of complexity
potentially in some cases and I think
we'd have to look at that at every
single system for example if I go out
and procure
um a system to do case management for
example for an HHS use case
um we certainly are looking to be able
to accept any document formats that are
generally being used out there would
that exclude some particular document
format it may so again just you know a
lot of application developers look at
all right what is for example web
browser I heard the web browser example
which is a really good one generally
what we look at is all right what's the
market share out there for any for for
and take the highest you know take the
high end of the market share what are
people actually using and addressing you
know that
that'll typically get most people happy
okay
thank you very much commissioner thank
you I think we will not vote on this at
the moment we're too confused
and I'll close does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill 617
seeing none I will close the hearing and
open the hearing on House Bill 284 and I
presume representative Aaron wants to
speak
foreign
thank you so much for uh having me come
and introduce this bill
I'm here today I'm representative Judy
Aaron representing
Sullivan County District 4 the towns of
Acworth Goshen Langdon lemster and
Washington
and I'm here today to introduce HB 284
this bill modifies and clarifies what is
prohibited from being made available to
the public regarding information
relative to rfbs
request for bids rfps requests for
proposals or rfas
cancellations requests for applications
constituents of mine
have been having difficulty getting
basic information about these
cancellations
and agencies are not answering any
questions about RFB RFP and rfas in
general
um
excuse me this bill seeks to clarify
that basic questions can be answered
I had this happen to me as well
when I was seeking information about an
RFP regarding Broadband expansion
the agency handling the RFP would not
give me any information about the
bidding process
or status or when a decision was going
to be made regarding a Broadband
granting process
my bill inserts new language to the RSA
stating that it is okay to provide
information about an RFP RFB or RFA
determination
um cancellation or non-selection as long
as it isn't information related to other
bids or other bidders
for far too long agencies have avoided
giving out any information to bidders
about or in or the public about any
cancellation process or status of a bid
by hiding behind parts of this statute
which is RSA
21-g colon 37.
clarification is therefore needed
because State agencies most likely
misinterpret this RSA or merely use it
as a reason not to answer questions at
all
examples of questions that have been
denied based on this RSA include
questions about when in an award might
be made the reasons why a solicitation
was canceled
if a new solicitation might be reissued
later on Etc
so when a bidder asks for simple and
basic information they are met with the
phrase quote state law restricts us from
commenting on any canceled solicitations
and they are quoted the link to the RSA
21-g colon 37 so for instance
the following questions can never get a
response what's the timeline or status
of this RFP why was this RFP canceled
what happens to the funding for this RFP
now that this RFP is canceled what are
the future plans for this RFP and will
they plan to reopen it again at another
time do we have to resubmit the
application if the RFP is reinstated
will my application be automatically
resubmitted if this RFP is reinstated
so none of those kinds of questions are
being answered they're all saying
we can't give you any information
so these questions have nothing to do
with other bids or other bidders and
they don't give anyone an unfair
advantage in the bidding process to the
questioner so why is this information
being prohibited from being provided by
the agency to the bidder asking the
questions
my new language changes this and allows
for basic information about the process
plans and status of an RFP RFB or RFA
so that the bidder can at least get an
idea of where the process is and what
the agency is planning for this RFP RFB
or RFA
this assists the bidder to plan
accordingly or at least know what is
going on
I also added a section to the statute
that inserts the following new paragraph
quote nothing in this chapter shall be
construed as a justification to avoid
answering questions posed by the public
or members of the general court that are
unrelated to information regarding other
bids or bidders to an RFB RFP RFA or
similar submission
and this further clarifies that an
agency cannot use this statute as
justification to not answer questions
unrelated to other bids or bidders
I believe that in the interest of Common
Sense and government transparency that
these changes need to be made to this
RSA and I hope that you will agree and
support this change to this statute
thank you madam chair as far as
chapter I mean um section eight nothing
in the chapter Shelby can show his
justification the last part
what is the penalty if they do not
disclose is this under the Privacy Act
or
I don't believe there's any penalty that
I'm aware of so you're asking them to
release information they haven't been
releasing so far
um well they they
should be releasing this information
because it doesn't
it doesn't have anything to do with
giving anybody an unfair advantage
follow up I agree with you what I'm just
getting at is generally government
doesn't do something unless they're
forced to do it so I mean asking seems
like it's not going to get anywhere
since we've been doing you've been doing
that so far and haven't gotten anywhere
that's what I'm concerned about thank
you yeah
it'll happen representative O'Brien
thank you madam Clerk and thank you
representative for taking my question
for my clarity
what is the difference between your bill
not sure
um
I don't know I don't know if uh right to
know comes into play with any of this it
probably should but uh clearly what
these agencies are doing are not
answering basic questions and saying
that statute prohibits them from
answering those questions so we're
trying to clear up the statute so that
they can see that they're they're not
violating anything by giving basic
information the uh
looking at the statute you gave us it
says notwithstanding the provisions of
RSA 91a so they're they're saying the
the bidding process is not
open
291a essentially that it's protected
okay I understand so evidently and her
bill says well you could still tell
these pieces of it to people I would
imagine the people who wrote RSA 91a had
this intention in mind when they
when they scribed it but that's
thank you very much thank you and I have
copies of my testimony so I'll pass them
foreign
thank you madam chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Derek Ferlin I'm the
County Manager for Sullivan County
I'm here to testify in support of House
Bill 284 and the amendment uh but my
testimony today is confined to the
original scope of House Bill 284 as it
was drafted
uh
at the risk of reiterating much of what
the bill sponsor representative Aaron
said I just wanted to share a little bit
of additional background
which led to the crafting of the of the
bill it's an experience that I had in
actually working with executive
departments on various matters uh the
RGA and the request for Grant
application process which is covered in
part by RSA 21g37
and I'll get to the specifics of of uh
of what I experienced shortly
um
as representative Aaron mentioned this
bill makes very small but I think there
are critical uh tweaks to this bill
language
um or to the RSA I think if I were to
infer legislative intent I could say
from my personal experience that the way
uh RSA 21g37 is being used is it's
actually being misunderstood and
therefore misused by some members of of
the executive departments
um just simply if and I included in in
the handout
as well as uh my cover letter with an
attachment I've actually got the build
text I wasn't sure if you all had that
readily available so I highlighted two
sections that I think really speak to
the confusion that's caused by the lack
of this uh added bit of clarity
um first of all start with this the
title uh financial information regarding
requests for bids and proposals so I
think that does set the tone for what
the legislative intent was behind this
law uh it's it's I think regarding
specific financial information
um and right in paragraph one uh the
highlighted part begins with concerning
specific responses to requests for bids
requests for proposals and requests for
applications
if you look at page two
paragraph six talks about when an agency
cancels one of these solicitations and
then it simply says no information other
than the notification of the
cancellation shall be available to the
public
etc etc so that's where I think that's
where the disconnect is because in
section one and following on with the
title of the of the RSA it's very clear
that this should be confined to specific
responses which makes perfect sense if
you're a contractor and you've submitted
a Paving project at dot you shouldn't go
in and be able to see what company a b
or c did for their bid that would be an
unfair uh competitive disadvantage for
for those bidders but as representative
Aaron said when the questions are Hey
when's the scoring going to uh happen
those are purely procedural process
related questions that have absolutely
nothing to do with any particular
submittal and yet the response typically
is sorry under RSA 21g37 can't tell you
anything and I can just tell you when
you're working on a Grant application
it's generally tied in the case of
Sullivan County our funding Stacks tend
to be pretty complex
because we don't have any money so we
have to seek multiple sources and so the
timeline of when those sources actually
you get approved or not they really
matter
so when you're trying to put together a
project that's reliant on various
sources of grant funding you know those
are that's a basic premise that's very
very important
um
so if you refer to the second page of of
my submittal this is just a quick
summary of uh of the timeline of I think
the most recent time that I ran into
this it was a couple years ago
um shortly after Cove had started so you
can just see in
um entry number one in April the RGA was
was due the submittals were due and so a
little over a month later I just emailed
and said hey I was just looking for an
update
um about a week later I got the response
cannot provide any for any information
uh during a procurement in accordance
with RSA 21g37
um and then if you skip down to uh entry
number eight this was in January 8th of
2021 so almost a year later
um I found out that the the RGA was
canceled and so those are the actual
questions uh that I asked why was it
canceled what will happen with the
funding will there be another RFP or RGA
issued later in the year and if the
answer is yes will those Auto
applications roll over automatically so
again nothing to do with any other
solicitation or submittal and certainly
nothing that would delve into the
financial particulars of any of those
submittals and so the last entry number
nine is is again verbatim the response
that I got and just just to note some of
the blanks
um I took the liberty of just sanitizing
this because I'm not my intent here is
not to throw a particular Department
under the bus and embarrass anybody I
just think it's a systemic problem that
really gets back to the lack of clarity
of section six and so I don't cast any
aspersions on a particular staff member
I just think it's just a little bit of
um the lack of clarity leads to the
misunderstanding
so I think uh that concludes my my
testimony I just wanted to give a bit of
additional information to show how this
RSA is implemented in in practice using
a real world example
um and I think this this minor tweak
will will go a long ways towards helping
provide better guidance maybe for the
executive department so that they can be
more responsive and provide information
when it's completely unrelated to any
other specific uh bids or the financial
information contained therein
thank you very much appending your
questions
representative Fitzpatrick uh thank you
madam chair I I think I understand it
now so I'm just going to give you a
scenario and see if if this is exactly
where you're going with this
you want to pave 10 miles worth of worth
of Roads you put it out to a bid the the
bids come in and you can't do 10 miles
the the prices are up you can only do
eight let's let's say you have to go
back to your new back to your governing
body and go through you know what are
you going to cut yada yada yada and
someone call but so you cancel the the
uh bids and you're gonna have to start
over again at a future time a citizen
calls you and says why are why were the
bids canceled you can't tell them that
is that what you're saying you can't
tell them that scenario that I just
that I just said they we couldn't afford
it we had a is that what you're saying
I would say I think in part yes I think
if if the answer was
um
the bids all exceeded available funding
that's not getting into the specific
Financial particulars of a specific
response
uh which again which is in section one
clearly states that you can't give out
specific bid responses right but if you
were just going to Simply respond to
that Citizen and say well we canceled it
because we didn't have enough money I
think that would be right now what you'd
get is I can't tell you anything right
so you couldn't tell them that yes
that's what I'm pardon me for following
up without per uh so okay uh thank you
your uh thank you uh thank you madam
chair I unders I understand then it is a
foreign
chair and members of the committee I
actually wanted to speak on uh
yeah my case we'll call we'll introduce
the amendment thank you
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on House Bill 284 not the
amendment
okay in that case I will call
Representative shuitt to present
amendment number
onest thank you madam chair uh for the
record I am representative Diane schuett
I represent the town of Pembroke
Merrimack 12 and I'm also a chair of the
Merrimack County delegation
um this amendment number
0320h I believe you all have coffees
is a non-germaine amendment that does
not change any language in the original
House fill 284 but simply would add to
it
this language originally went to another
Committee in the house as House Bill 148
which voted it in expedient to legislate
based not on the content but rather
simply because the sponsor was unable to
present introduce it and speak to it
we were able to get that bill laid on
the table when it came before the house
so that the language could be brought
forward again
that is the amendment you see before you
it basically enables all 10 counties to
avoid requesting bids on items or
Services under ten thousand dollars
there are several others here who can
explain the reasoning behind it the time
and costs this would save our counties
and our taxpayers and probably answer
any questions you may have on the
um thank you are there any questions
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
schuett
so am I correct in understanding that
this replacement I'm not seeing anything
in here that changes the nature of the
information that would get released that
was in the original Bill we talked about
this this amendment would not change
anything in 284. okay it just adds the
contents of houseville 148 to it okay to
thank you
yes
it's an add-on not a replace all right a
friendly amendment I would say right
okay representative Gerhart thank you
madam chair
I think we spoke about this earlier at
the county delegation but I'm just
concerned about the transparency aspect
of this so if we're going from five to
ten thousand is there any way to make
all of these purchase purchases that are
in that zone that's changed the five to
ten thousand dollar range more publicly
accessible instead of having to go
through the 91a route or I'm just
curious that was ever entered your
um I would say to ask that question of
the folks who are the prime sponsor of
148 is here and I would say he'd be
better equipped to answer that thank you
okay
anyone else okay thank you
representative schuette representative
Edwards
yeah hi uh for the record I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31 Auburn Chester
sand down excuse me Candia and uh
Deerfield redistricting I still haven't
rewound my tape yet I uh all four towns
are in Rockingham County I'm the prime
sponsor of HB 148.
um I
I I screwed up I failed to show up at
the introduction briefing or hearing for
148 so it was a good bill then it's a
good bill now it has a tremendous amount
of support because I didn't show up uh
the the chair's position was to
recommend itl and it's too good of a
bill to let that happen to it so
um one thing that representative schuett
did not mention is just how gracious
she's been to step in to an area where I
where I'm clearly screwed up and and has
stepped up and done the right thing for
the counties and I just think that's
great teamwork it's a good bill we've
got
um the commissioner here from Rockingham
to talk about it to your issue on
transparency representative I I you know
our the counties are very transparent in
General on the budget and as I think
about the county budget I've seen in the
lists of Acquisitions I've seen I don't
I don't know where this new range of of
purchases between the the new ones five
to ten thousand I don't know where those
would show up but but what we're is so
that's a that's a fair question and I
and the reason we're raising it is
because this this has not been raised
since 1998 that's when the five thousand
dollars went into effect and so if you
go look at the inflation scale uh five
thousand and 1998 is about nine thousand
now so I picked ten thousand dollars
because that's what the counties told me
they wanted but but it but it actually
works out so with that
um I take questions if there are any
okay thank you
thank you thank you
thank you madam chair and committee
members it's uh it's nice to be back at
the State House I
I was in your seats for a while for 10
years from 2010 to 2020 I see some
familiar faces and some new faces but uh
I appreciate being able to address the
committee um as representative Edwards
had mentioned the 5000 number was
basically in 1998 and if you do the
inflationary costs it basically was like
it comes out to 92 so we just rounded it
to 10. uh and I just want to give you an
example of
um why this would be beneficial for the
county so in my county in Rockingham
County we we actually have an outside
vendor that does all of the the food
service
and they also take care of all of our
meals for wheels for Rockingham County
which is there's a they produce a lot of
meals we had an issue with a piece of
kitchen equipment
that was over five thousand dollars now
we knew where we could get the equipment
but according to the law I have to put
out the bid so we basically were down
with equipment for three three or four
days so that kind of put a little bit of
a
a crinkle on that that's how this came
to be and we looked at it and we said
well 5000 really doesn't get it's really
not much now so
um we're asking I mean it's as simple as
that we're asking to to go to 10
um there's nothing else
um really to be said but but just that
so it just gives us a little bit more
wiggle room
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
all right thank you representative has a
question and it sounds specific well
specific to Rockingham so in the
amendment that representative schuett
submitted there's a specific clause in
RSA it's 28-e that refers to Hillsboro
and there's a specific Clause that
report that refers to Rockingham
but that's not in this amendment so is
that are you thinking that the top of it
is going to it's actually 28 colon 8f I
don't see that any Amendment it's on
I am so sorry no that's okay thank you
thank you you're welcome yes so that I'd
like to ask on that absolutely the
Rockingham County at one time had a
unique bidding process but if we make
this change you'll use the same as nine
as eight other counties
yes um my understanding is as we
discussed as counties collectively we we
always discuss things together
um and uh it it basically
um would help them as well
so that's where that came to be um and
then of course the Cabo for Hillsborough
County because it's specific in the in
the language in the
in the law so this would include all all
counties all 10 counties
except Hillsborough
um well you've got Hillsborough on the
bottom correct yes yeah and the rest of
them are in the uh the rest of them
right exactly exactly that's that we
have to word it that way because
Hillsborough has its own section
and they and they wanted they also
wanted the the benefit of the 10th I
mean obviously Hillsborough County being
the largest
I'm glad we will hear from Hillsborough
County yes I can explain why they need
their own special piece of Statute yeah
thank you manager okay uh Ross
Cunningham
yes
good afternoon Madam chair Ross
Cunningham
um I am the
County Administrator for Merrimack
County
um 34 plus years of government service
hence my hair loss so good afternoon to
all of you
um I'd like to give you a kind of a
brief reason why Merrimack County is
supportive of this change for many
reasons and I can give you a snapshot in
2022 just in the bracket of the 5000. we
did 37 formal bids in that bracket and
on average every one of those bid
packets because we have a central
purchasing process it's about 20 to 30
staff hours it takes to process each one
of those so you can imagine the tasking
it takes to do that work and do it in an
open transparent way and I think what I
would say to you is if it changes from
five to ten thousand dollars the reality
doesn't change for us of how a process
is processed the fact of the matter it's
the tasking involved with the inflation
in the other arguments that were given
to you earlier I can tell you that that
it is awful taxing at times I've worked
in two counties both Sullivan and
Merrimack and they are at times can be
problematic in in a situation where you
have a down piece of equipment or you're
pursuing a service and those things are
complicated in this world we're trying
to work in today post covet other than
that I didn't really have any other
testimony uh then to tell you I am in
support of it and
um if you have any questions of myself
thank you further questions
okay so may I confirmed that you said
that in one year you had 37 rfps in this
price range yes ma'am okay thank you and
the average time is 20 to 30 hours that
three staff hours okay excuse me 20 to
30 hours of Staff time to process each
one okay which gets numbered and we
score and then they're presented to the
Board of Commissioners for final
authorization that's the rest of the
story as they unfold of course all right
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is David Ross
and I am the administrator of
Hillsborough County Nursing Home
I do stand here in support of the
amended House Bill 284 to increase that
threshold from five thousand dollars to
ten thousand dollars
we are finding that so many products now
are included at that five thousand
dollar level
it is rapidly increasing the number of
our fees that we're having to do for
products that are insignificant to
business operations such as styrofoam
cups
um for example
um and as Mr Cunningham shared the RFP
process is extremely labor intensive for
us but it's also time intensive in that
the time it takes to prepare the RFP for
vendors to be able to review and submit
a proposal for us to be able to make the
bid award and to
um procure the products it delays
business operations for now at that five
thousand dollar level for so many
products that really are insignificant
back in 1998 when this level was set
um since then the price of household
paper goods according to the U.S Bureau
of Labor Statistics has increased 125
percent and we are definitely seeing
that at our end so we just ask that we
um that you approve that so that we can
focus our energy where it really belongs
on business operations and on products
that are of substantial significance to
business operations it does not increase
the amount of money that can be spent it
doesn't have any impact on budgets it
does not change our responsibility to be
stewards
um and our fight or our fiduciary
responsibility
Hillsborough County does have a separate
statute here that dictates what the
requirements are for competitive bidding
and what the analysis is for bid award
and we are not asking for that to change
that does help us very much to ensure a
consistent and thorough process and we
are all very satisfied with that the
other counties are satisfied with their
process and we appreciate your
consideration of that
thank you madam chair my name is Kate
Horgan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties coming around
you will see a letter in support uh from
the association as well as Merrimack
County's written testimony just so that
you know that that is coming around so
you should take two and here comes
Hillsboro's
um so we are in support of this
legislation and uh can I just say ditto
to what my members have stated they did
a great job explaining it
um it's it's merely an inflation thing
for us
um so I'm happy to take any questions
but I think they did a great job
explaining though
are there any questions from the
committee
okay seeing none thank you very much
all right
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 284 or its
Amendment
okay
seeing none I will close the public
hearing
[Music]
all right
and open the public hearing on
what's the next time
Madam chair were you recognizing me yes
I'm sorry I didn't I didn't quite hear I
apologize uh thank you madam chair and
thank you honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent rockinghamton
that is New Market and new fields and I
am here to introduce hb359 the effect of
which it would be to establish a legal
holiday for election day as well as uh
primary election days
so the main issue that I want to kind of
bring up is one of voter turnout uh
obviously a self-governing body only
works when people actually show up to
self-govern on the days that we have
these things we call elections
New Hampshire is the fourth highest
state in the country and I say State
because I'm about to go somewhere else
with that and yet our voter turnout is
under 60 percent in in a good year
for most years the United States in
general however
while we are fourth in the in the
country for a state the United States in
general is 31st in the world so as
self-governing goes we aren't doing that
great a job of making sure that we are
all actually making sure that all of our
voices are being heard
I brought up State specifically because
we do have a place in the country
that excels at voter turnout and that is
Puerto Rico on the island of Puerto Rico
voter turnout in a mid uh off year is in
the 80s percentages and in a
presidential year is in the 90s
so I'm kind of looking at those numbers
enviously even though we're fourth
amongst States
um however when Puerto Ricans moved to
the mainland
their voter turnout drops even beneath
regular voter turnout so why is this
this is strange why why is it that
Puerto Ricans have such high amazingly
High voter turnout high high in you know
even amongst World numbers and yet drops
to under 50 percent when they come to
the mainland the Puerto Ricans have a
holiday for their election day
and there's two levels to this so the
first and most obvious I'll talk about
first and that is
um having a holiday obviously gives
people the time to vote specifically
working people it specifically gives
people who otherwise might have to work
or might not know when they have to work
on Election Day
um and so not be able to even fill out
an absentee ballot ahead of time because
as you know our absentee ballots require
an affidavit for one of four reasons
and so if you don't know that you're
going to have to work ahead of time and
then it turns out you do have to work
then you don't have the ability to fill
out that absentee ballot
um but then when you do work and you
know just imagine your average American
life you have to take the kids to school
go to work work all day come back pick
the kids up maybe there's a soccer game
maybe there's a recital of some sort
make dinner this is very difficult for
people the alternative is to have a day
off where you can celebrate the entire
day and have a specific time and
everybody's time could be different but
work it in and then bring the children
into that scenario so that they can
learn what self-governance is all about
what small D democracy having a republic
is indeed all about
so that's the time issue and that one is
the obvious one and just so you're aware
the reason our federal elections are on
Tuesday was
um the best effort by our Founders I I
teach American government and Community
College or I haven't for for several
semesters and they did that
intentionally because this was a time
when we didn't have such a thing as a
nine to five office job everyone was a
farmer people were farmers and everyone
went to church so if everyone Farms but
then everybody goes to church on Sunday
you take Sunday you give people one day
of travel because travel was slow back
then and then we held our elections on
Tuesday so the framers did their
absolute best to have elections on a day
that was were the most accessible it was
the most accessible for the most people
we should be duplicating that intent
today to get as many people involved in
voting as possible
and I would just add with all of the
kind of unrest and unhappiness that we
see on both in both political spectrums
with our government government that a
lot of that can be addressed by making
sure more people's voices are actually
heard people will not feel as
unrepresented as they do by their
government if more people have a say in
that government
so that's the turnout piece the actual
time to turn out but there's another
reason that Puerto Rico
um in their election day holiday is so
important and that is it's not simply a
day off it is a holiday in the truest
sense they celebrate democracy they
celebrate the idea of self-governance
the the fact that they get to have a say
and in the irony of course being that
they get to have a say far less than we
in the states do uh in the action in an
actual state but they still celebrate
they celebrate it with things they call
caravanas which are these parades
um and so I'm imagining for election day
holiday it's not simply a day off I'm
thinking of things like barbecues and
parties and debates and mock elections
and things that really truly celebrate
the idea that we get to have a say in
our government which was truly radical
and if you think about it as a holiday
any type of holiday approaches you as a
work working person you're aware you're
more aware of that day because it's a
day that you have off so it's marked on
the calendar it's coming up you know
that it's coming you're starting to make
plans with family you're making plans
with friends
so Fourth of July a day that we have to
celebrate the creation of our country
the creation of our great experiment in
self-government Memorial Day a day that
we celebrate the people who died for our
democracy Veterans Day a day that we
celebrate the people who fight for our
democracy President's Day a day that we
celebrate the people who have served our
democracy we have all of these days and
more Columbus Day we can argue is the
day that is celebrating the discovery by
Europeans of the new world which led to
us having our democracy and our great
experiment in self-governance so all of
these days we have off to celebrate the
idea of self-governance but the day that
we actually do the self-governance we
don't have off does not make sense to me
so I think setting it aside as a day
onto its own where we know it's coming
up we see it in the calendar we know we
have it off
um will really help instill the Civic
discourse and the Civic engagement we
all believe we should have more of in
so I want to get into the bones of the
bill
so the first paragraph is the existing
paragraph on state holidays and
um it turns out that election day is
already in our list of state recognized
holidays which got me searching for why
the heck is it the only day that of the
list in the paragraph that we don't
actually have off
um and it turns out that there was no
actual definition for what this list
meant so there was a list in our rsas of
what state holidays were the list of
state holidays but no description of
what that actually meant what happens on
a state holiday
so I created that description and I
described what currently happens on
holidays such as Christmas or
Thanksgiving Veterans Day and all the
days that I already listed Washington's
birthday Independence Day all of these
are already listed so essentially I say
that public offices to the extent that
they're not necessary close down on that
day
that includes schools many schools are
already closed on Election Day because
those locations are polling places
anyway but uh but I am very clear to say
first of all that if the governmental
unit be it a county a a municipality
what have you decides that
um a function is necessary then that
obviously doesn't close so we're not
closing for example uh police
departments fire departments things of
that nature we're also not closing
anything that's required to run the
elections obviously that goes without
saying and then finally nothing in this
would interfere with any particular
bargaining unit negotiating for a
different day instead of they can
negotiate whatever days they like
um so that only affects the public
sector the effect of this is essentially
because we have
a year without any election and then
we'll have a year with a primary and a
general so on average you get one day a
year the effect is one school day
per year one snow day per year right
that is the equivalent which really
doesn't have a financial impact you may
argue it has a productivity impact
because you're still paying people and
they're getting a day off that since
that is effectively paid except for the
hourly workers but I would argue a day
where people are coming in late leaving
early or taking long lunch breaks in
order to vote isn't a terribly
productive day anyway and you're saving
on overhead in hourly employees anyway
so I think it's a wash which is probably
why it does not have a fiscal note
um having said that this touches all
everything I've gone through so far does
not touch the private sector whatsoever
of course we do not ever mandate that
the any private sector any private
company close
um so gas stations restaurants all of
those things are already able to be open
on days like Christmas anyway I do say
in the last paragraph that all employers
shall when practicable allow employees
up to three hours away from work which
would be unpaid there's no requirement
to pay them to cast ballots in those
elections
so
the last thing I want to add and this is
only because in a year past when I
introduced this I had um
someone from the Teachers Association
speak and support and that was the year
that we dealt as the body with another
issue that dealt with schools and that
is the concept of guns and schools
versus guns at polling places and he
testified in favor of my bill because
this solves that particular problem
because if you don't have children
present at the schools then you don't
have to worry about guns being at the
schools while children are present and
you don't have to you know worry about
restricting the the ability to carry
guns so I think I've touched on pretty
much everything so I'll I'm happy to
take questions
I I would just like to say that I notice
you don't include the local elections
yes I do not include they do matter
Madam chair and I it would be extremely
onerous to do that because every
municipality has a different day of
local elections so if it was something
that the committee did you know feel
strongly about I would absolutely
support doing that
thank you are there any other questions
for representative Reed
Jim Gerhart
thank you madam chair
the people that I know that don't vote
they're intentionally not voting because
they don't believe there's any
difference between the parties
especially at the federal level so I
don't know how this would really affect
that
um and then okay so that's my comment on
that thank you other quick any questions
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for coming in and
testifying um my question for you is you
gave a really beautiful description of
what you would love this day to look
like
um and it certainly sounds like a great
thing but I'm not sure how your bill
accomplishes that
um
coming from a specific sector of
society we work through all of the
holidays all of them
um and as a part of the private sector
for us a lot of times these kind of
things seem like we're paying for
somebody else to have a day off and gain
an advantage essentially they've got
more access to the polls than
potentially we do
um what feedback would you give from
that perspective thank you I'm uh I'm
not sure what you mean by paying for
other people because typically those
positions are tax funded so if we're
closing like Town Offices State offices
those people are getting paid through
tax dollars we typically pay those taxes
okay all right so
um while I do give the private sector
three hours to go vote so that's already
an improvement for the private sector if
you're talking about like kind of
broader culture stuff so let you can say
Christmas Day for example almost all but
not all private sector companies close
on Christmas day
um why is that there's no mandate that
they close it's cultural so
I think the first one not specifically
with Christmas because it's been with us
for a very long time but in general
Banks and other kind of like
white-collar jobs those places tend to
like follow the public holidays and so
they start to close then you would see
more and more kind of businesses until
you reached like I doubt that a lot of
retail would close or what have you but
it's it's a process because as more
people start to have the day off there's
more demand for other people to have the
day off to enjoy in the activities that
that segment gets to enjoy in so when
you have a large percentage of having
the day off then you're going to start
to see events concerts in the park
barbecues fireworks things like that and
so then there's more reason for those
people to negotiate either privately or
just kind of broader in the broader
culture have those days off together
follow up
thank you madam chair just just as um
feedback to that I suppose um
some some people myself included might
feel that actually as more people have
that time off it creates more work for
certain sectors that are actually
providing the services that everybody
else is and just enjoying thank you and
and as I have in the bill nothing so as
there's pressure it also improves so if
you're in a sector that for example has
a union
you can negotiate and you have more
leverage to negotiate to have a day off
even if that day has to be a different
day if you're in a sector that
specifically needs to fill in when other
people have the day off you can
negotiate for a separate day off but at
any rate you will have three hours off
so it in any any way you slice this it
is still an improvement for the vast
majority of people to have a more access
but be more cultural support and I will
just add as a comment to the previous
comment that whilst it is true and I
would agree to a large extent with the
people that you may associate with that
don't be able that aren't able to turn
out or don't turn out because they don't
feel like they have a lot of choice and
there are in fact reforms that can help
help with that significantly that this
is still a barrier for a lot of people
and a cultural barrier and as we start
to celebrate the idea of self-governance
and civil discourse and discourse with
people that we disagree with prime often
times but able to do so in a civil way
in a way that actually furthers our
apology policy that more and more people
will start to feel like their votes
actually matter and maybe having more
people makes the two parties listen to
us more if more people vote so that's
what I would say to that
thank you very very much for your answer
um hi I'm representative Gallagher again
um
so
yeah I think representative Reed did a
pretty good job preventing presenting
the bill
um so I'll try not to repeat here and
just keep it short but I think it's a
good idea and I swear that I've had this
idea independently before I'd ever heard
of anyone seriously proposing
legislation for it so
um
yeah it's that's something I've been
thinking about for a while
um I I definitely love election days
um you know just the chance of going to
the polls and
seeing people I don't really see any
other time of the year there
um it already is kind of like a holiday
and I think
having some recognition from the
government that for many people is like
a holiday
would
um
would mean a lot to people
so
yeah please support this bill and I'll
take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions
uh no not today
thank you madam chair and
um thank you for the committee I feel
like everything that I was going to say
was covered so I guess I'm just going to
keep this really short
um I'm not really sure what I can add
except uh as a mom specifically one who
works seven days a week
this just kind of seems like a
no-brainer to me if our goal is to
accommodate robust and participate
participatory elections with as much
input from as many people as possible
um and there is such thing as a
designated holiday I think that this
makes sense this is what it should be
um yeah I mean that's basically what
everything else thank you very much are
there any questions
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right not seeing any I will close
all right
in that case we are
through with our day and there are no
full committee activities for the next
two weeks I hope everyone will work on
the bills we have already heard
and go go to session thank you very much
well just uh the notice is out there's a
licensing subcommittee meeting tomorrow